[Music]
welcome everyone to
to our council meeting
um firstly any
i must do me a apologies to two and
hopefully all plan will be back by
twenty past two
okay any further apologies
apart from that which is noted by
council brian thank you for advising
you'll move that the apology so the
council of duty is going to move that
secreted by council williams for that
brief apology for council brian all
those in favor i
contrary to clear that carried
under conflicts of interest
i just just um
want to advise that in the public uh
today we are considering
a paper on the publicly excluded by wow
trust
it's a pre-feasibility study update
for the purposes of openness and
transparency
i would like to disclose that last year
when the wow trust was seeking
crowdfunding
for the kaiboy water park proposal
i made a personal donation of 50 dollars
as i wanted to see the pre-feasibility
work undertaken i just want to put that
on the public record
sorry
and me too
yes yes i've made a donation also
yes mr mayor i made a donation also to
the
pre-feasibility study only
we come to acknowledgements
and firstly i'd just like to recognize
those who were successful with queen's
birthday birthday honours at the weekend
um
aarahar rarity crofts
now dame aruha was made a dame companion
of the new zealand
order of merit
among a long list of achievements araha
is known to us all as councils kamatua
lintiaca was made a member of the new
zealand order of merit for services
to maori education
david carrera was made a member of the
new zealand order of merit for services
to mountaineering and outdoor recreation
and christopher marshall of ahoka has
made a qsm
for services to music
it's fantastic that four members of our
community have been recognised for
outstanding public service
we're very proud of all of them for what
they do and for those that aren't
recognised actually but this year it's
very special particularly
um
day maraha that was magnificent for her
to make that achievement
um i will on behalf of the council i
will write to each
of those who've received and pass on our
congratulations but wish to acknowledge
those here today
right any other acknowledgements
so we come to confirmation of minutes
item 4.1
minutes of the meeting
are held on the 5th of may pages twelve
to twenty five do i have a somewhat
appear to move
moved by councillor atkinson seconded by
councillor barnett
any discussion
all those in favor aye
contrary declare that carried
item 4.2 minutes of the px we'll deal
with those in
publicly excluded section
any matters arising
deputations and presentations i haven't
been advised of any
we come now to a june business uh the
first is item 6.1
and that's sophie allen who i understand
is going to join us
adrian is that correct
just wait a couple of minutes while that
gets set up
is she going to be on the screen or
well i'm this is sophie here i'm present
hi so if you're welcome to our meeting
we can't hear you yet so i'll just i'll
clip off my
microphone and see if that makes
difference you able to hear me now
you are mute dear sophie so
us anyway
are you gonna hear me now
um
hmm
anybody hear me now
okay
[Music]
item is
7.1 covert related reports pages 38-49
mr palmer
sorry
thank you mr mia this report is
a
assessment of the
covert situation as we understand it
today
we've attempted to
develop
a
risk register that
identifies the particular covert risks
that we intend tracking and monitoring
and so
today that's for your
uh consideration and we'd welcome any
feedback on your views as to our
assessment of that risk and
how we're managing that
while there are
there are a number of risks related
to the covert
virus
as it impacts our council and this
assessment is a council-only assessment
the key issues that we
are concerned about
initially from a health and safety point
of view and thankfully i just see that
we've now had our 11th day with no new
cases which is
great news
for
us all
while health and safety was the
particular concern initially with that
now seeming to be not the key issue
certainly the economic impact of this is
something which we are still
concerned about and see that that has
both some potentially significant
impacts for both the council and our
district as i've signaled earlier i
think there are many other
parts of the
country and the world for that matter
that will fare worse than waimakariri
because of the particular
characteristics that waimakariri have or
the features of waimakariri
but nonetheless there is likely to be an
impact and i
suspect that
while we're at level two and may go to
level one soon awaiting the government's
advice on that um
that may lessen the immediate impact i
think might concern more as with the
broader global
economic impact and what that may do
subsequently to the new zealand economy
so we're watching that particularly
closely
and at a council level um over the next
several months in particular we'll be
closely monitoring the
impact on our business
demand for our services our consenting
services for building consent and
resource consent
which has a significant impact on our
activity as well as some other
types of business like our learn to swim
schools which currently we're only
partially operating through level two
i'm just seeing what the
return of business is there while it's
been promising initially we will need to
keep monitoring that on an ongoing basis
so that is certainly what we perceive as
being our most significant risk at this
time there are a number of others which
you'll have seen in the assessment that
we've that we've looked at and
uh
through our various mitigation actions
taken uh managed those risks to
what we think is a reasonably low or
manageable level but i'd be happy to
take any questions or feedback that you
might have in regard to the report
thank you mr palmer any questions
council stuart
thank you mr mayor i note on page
um the first page of your report um the
six
um
these six cases in canterbury active
cases at the time of writing
do we have any update on that i um you
indicated you just heard that we were
11th day
um with no new cases i last i heard
there was one active case in the country
is that still active and is it do we
know whether it's local
i haven't checked what the update is
today in that regard but there is the
last advice was that there is one active
case in new zealand and that's a that's
uh associated with a cluster in auckland
uh so there are there are no cases that
i'm aware of in canterbury it's it's
interesting just to see how how fast the
world picture is
uh changing though at the time
um
we drafted this report there were five
nearly five million cases where we're
now at 6.3 6.4 million
and
considerably more deaths than the 315
that are noted here but
yeah it has certainly changed quickly in
new zealand
dsa for the good
wrong way they can
any further questions counselor duty
thank you
and just a query please with us with our
other associated meetings uh do you
do you think we'd still be doing them by
zoom or we're actually physically in
here
it's like yeah committee meetings and
our perhaps our
community board meetings
different things like that
uh
very much looking to do them in person
um and i think uh next week's meeting
well there's an oxford community board
meeting tomorrow
night which
is happening in person uh here i believe
um but yeah the intent is to
hold all those meetings in person
um
yes very much so
any further questions so we have a serie
a recommendation yeah someone prepared
to move
moved councillor duty seconded
councillor um redmond
any discussion counselor duty
thank you very much for that report it
was um
very well written and
um it's given us great debt of food for
thought as to
just how lucky we are in our situation
here at present so long may that last
council redmond
thank you mr mayor there is still one
active case in the country in the north
island so we are very lucky in the south
island and there's a strong likelihood
we'll be moving to level one next week
so i guess mr palmer will need to assess
the implications of that again as we go
through these various levels so thank
you very much for a comprehensive report
thank you any further speakers
write a reply counselor duty
so i'll put the put the recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried
so are we in a position to come back to
6.1 do you think or would you like a bit
more time
a little more time bits
yes
okay all right well we can come back to
that um before
a we later anyway and if need be we'll
deal with it sorry
thank you
thanks jimmy
next
the next item is 7.2 which is the
covert recovery plan and that's reporter
name of simon heart pages
50-68
mr heart thank you welcome to our
meeting
thank you mr mayor and good afternoon
councillors
uh simon markham will be joining us very
shortly he's just been caught up with
something
um so the purpose of this report
is to formally seek council support to
lead the development and an
implementation of a district recovery
plan in conjunction with our community
partners
we're doing this under the brand better
than before acknowledging that this is a
great place to live and work but we can
come out of this event a lot stronger
as we've learned from the earthquake
recovery process
recovery is about building the plane as
we fly it and you'll note that there are
already a number of national programs
and local programs that are underway uh
as as we continue to build this
this recovery plan but
with the events still unfolding and us
yet to know what that final event
damage or impact will look like
now is a really important time for us to
progress the development of this
recovery plan for the district and to to
move that process forward
this report
notes that it is important for us to
stay open to changes
um but we still need to confirm a
structure and a process to go forward
with this recovery and so that is a
recommendation in front of you today the
report also discusses the early benefits
of
wider community
consultation and engagement
we already have some really good
existing social service sector networks
and we would like to discuss with you
the establishment of an economic
recovery advisory group to help better
inform us and provide us with economic
insights as we go into this recovery
with both an economic and a social feel
to it
i'll take the report as read but i will
just highlight a few things from the
report as we go through
you'll note that
this event is unprecedented in nature in
our lifetime
it emerged out of china in december in
2019 and since that time to the end of
may
more than 5 million confirmed cases have
been recorded across 188 countries with
sadly almost 325 000 deaths
new zealand's response has been
considered to be very very good
and that is highlighted on page 52 graph
which shows us
shows china the origin of the event and
then it shows the us who's tracking
quite high of course
today there is only one confirmed case
of covert in new zealand which is
quite remarkable from a public health
perspective
however the impact of this will be quite
significant and we note the
unprecedented depth destruction
accumulation of likely debt
and job losses in new zealand
and this in turn will have a significant
psychosocial community
impact as well
at a national level treasury projections
uh suggesting that real gdp will decline
from about 2.8 percent at the end of
2019 so around minus five percent
in 2020 and over the same period of time
unemployment will go from around four
percent
to more likely 10
and some economic economists across the
country are suggesting that these these
are quite conservative figures
either way continuing to assess how this
particular pandemic will affect our
district is really really important
and we need to assess as we go on how we
can best mobilize the available
resources that we have to address the
issues here in our district
uh through this recovery planning
process and we need to note that this is
probably more likely to be a marathon in
nature rather than a sprint it's a two
to five year kind of time frame that
we're looking at
on your page 53 you'll note that we've
included
a diagram which describes some of the
economic blockages that are occurring
across the world and here in new zealand
and then further down in terms of gdp
and unemployment rate on page 54 we've
highlighted the significance of the
covet event in gdp terms we've we've
highlighted that in that first graph
compared with the global financial
crisis of 2009-2010
and then the second graph we highlight
the steep incline and unemployment
compared with previous periods
locally we've done some initial
assessments both from an economic and a
social recovery perspective
uh enc enterprise north canterbury have
undertaken around 705 business
assessments that's more than double what
they would normally do in a year
a year and and that 705 was undertaken
in a two-month period so it sort of
indicates the increase in
business anxiety if you like
and and at the same time registered job
seekers with the ministry of social
development has increased from around
550 to over 1200 in this district so we
are starting to see the impact of this
occur and i would note that those
numbers uh are occurring at the same
time as well this tia how are you stuart
immediate response packages i'm having
uh one of my usual council days um
i can't get sophie sound to work it
seems
[Music]
they they highlight that from a
psycho-social and community perspective
these sorts of events have a bigger
impact on some parts of our community
than on other parts and and those that
have higher risk are those who are at
higher risk of contracting covert of
course
people with pre-existing health issues
yeah but i'm just scared that sophie
won't be able to actually
zoom in for the last one as well lost
their job or their household
major concern
people who have had cultural religious
values or customs interrupted
and children and young people
over the longer longer term period
under section 4 of this report also
we just note the unprecedented
legislative
and uh fiscal um
that had that had been resolved yes put
in place in the immediate and it was
working perfectly and then just know
that that's like i can hear it
but the guys the counselors
locally its um
initial recovery planning has begun and
you've seen through briefings the six
programs we've put together with the 27
projects this is our long list of course
of potential projects
we would like to
do some more um consultation with some
key stakeholders in our community and of
course further conversations with
council to refine that list into a more
concise list for a final recovery plan
and we think that's important as part of
that to follow the principles noted in
4.5
towards the end of section 4 on page 57
you'll see a couple of images we thought
were pretty good the first one from
ariana huffington
which i think nicely reflects the better
than before uh slogan that we're pushing
with this
recovery planning process and the second
one some key considerations we think
really important to keep in the back of
our mind as we go forward and continue
this planning process
then at 4.10 and 4.11
we just talk about
the
economic recovery advisory group that we
have
proposed
there's a terms of reference for that
and the attachments of course
and uh just seeking council's approval
to have the chief executive and mia
start to have some initial conversations
with leaders within the relative sectors
that might be involved in that group
and finally under section 5 the
financial implications section just
noting that of course
any final recovery plan would need to
have consideration of funding
once we've confirmed what programs and
projects may eventually end up in that
program but of course in the interim
there is a sum of
a provisional sum of half a million
dollars in the annual plan for a
two-year period to get us started on
this journey of recovery planning and
delivery
simon if there's any other notes you'd
like to make otherwise very happy to
take any questions mr mayor
thank you mr hart any questions
counselor becky followed by councillor
thank you
simon um page 55 3.17 that
cultural and religious values
interrupted and impacting um and and
especially the funeral thing in what way
do you think council can be involved in
in i mean bearing in mind it's been and
gone in what way do you think we can be
involved in remedying that that type of
situation bearing in mind that those
groups although they were they were very
inconvenienced they're they're well
established um you know
in their own right
yes it's a really good observation um
and i think as you as you mentioned
uh as the uh restriction levels ease
those interruptions are also reduced and
we're starting to see a greater
allowance for our religious and cultural
customs and practices
back within our community
my hope is that that will continue as
the restrictions ease but certainly our
community team led by tessa sturley
have some really strong networks in the
social service sector and i think
they're doing some excellent work
establishing what
uh the the precise
issues that we might need to adjust
through a recovery plan and um and and
thinking about how we might do that
yes thank you simon just two questions
from me first of all we learned from the
earthquake that it was good to take the
community with us quite early and get
their input how are you looking to
involve elected members in the wider
community
in the early stages of this recovery
plan
uh the
first note would be um
we're putting together a community
consultation and engagement plan i think
uh that needs to be a little further
detailed but that's the beginning of us
putting together what the journey with
the council and our community might look
like certainly the the formation of the
economic
recovery advisory group and the
significant network that exists within
our social services sector and our
community team will really help to
provide us with the basis of that
consultation
and conversation
certainly also our next steps will
include a series of meetings and further
conversations with council
and and our engagements of course will
certainly consider how councillors can
be involved
any further comment on this one
and of course community boards as well
yes thank you
the second question was obviously
central government's going to be doing a
whole lot of recovery initiatives going
forward how will we avoid duplication
and how will we coordinate with them
so it's a very good question because
there is certainly a lot of amount of
central government funding uh being
allocated
we are
seeking to inventory what actually is
available to us in in into this district
so that
as you um
as we further develop the program of
projects
we are in any decisions that you might
be making about funding are conscious of
what central government's putting on the
table
so
that's a piece of work that
we hope we can come bring back to you in
july council
and literally almost almost by the day
additional funds are being
allocated so
it is it is continuing to move but we
had that comment with um
the
uh regional manager of msd
that uh they're in as part of our core
recovery group meeting a week or so back
that
there there are a range of initiatives
across different government agencies
and of course we sort of sit here
looking up and expect them to be all
self-aware of what each arm of
government are doing and that at times
is not quite the case so
we're actually in quite a good position
to put that picture together although
um it would be helpful if that was
already
available to
councils up and down the country as well
council stuart
uh thank you mr mayor just a couple of
questions that follow on rudy from
council obama which is
the time i mean this is a a massive
document to work through this report
the time frame for getting the plan
operational
um
how speedy are you going to be in
getting all this together
oh sorry
thank you
so
um
following this
report we hope to go out
have initial conversations with the
economic recovery advisory group
potential members start to
do some initial consultation and
engagement around
projects six programs which is the long
list start to get some feedback on that
so that we can bring back some more con
informed conversation uh with council
looking to july to to put in front of
council
a very early draft of a recovery plan
which would include a refined list of
those programs and projects
and as simon said
considers also some of the funding
streams both centrally and then what's
left over
uh and so so july would be a key date
for us and then following that
confirmation of a plan and then
implementation but as i say we we have
been flying the plane as it's being
built so there are already recovery
actions underway both nationally and
locally
one other question and
i'm aware that this council is um has
applied in conjunction with ecan and
christchurch city for
environmental type projects that ecan is
coordinating
where in your
this document and your
list of projects does that fit because
it didn't immediately
strike me where it fitted
uh it's a good question and uh it there
are two areas or two possible projects
that fits under it
it it can be grouped with
councils what it's doing and
accelerating its capital program
how we're leveraging the shovel ready um
projects
um
and and undoubtedly though those sort of
funds are going to be seeking
partnership funding with councils it's
not all
uh unless we are optimistically mistaken
uh it's not all going to be money that
shoveled out of wellington
so we will need to consider how to
balance
uh what is um
uh co-investment by the government with
what is reasonable and appropriate
locally so it fits in that area i think
also it fits a little bit in the green
economy project and we've
we've coined a project called green
economy which is how do we
using the royal we leverage the recovery
out of this disaster with some of the
bigger picture sustainability climate
change kind of
issues that council will be wrestling
with
in any event
and
and so you you're seeing in the national
dialogue particularly let out of the
climate change commission
uh seeking for government to apply that
lens and the way it allocates
uh shovel really projects money how a
ministry for the environment and
department of conservation operate in
terms of the funding that they would be
administering out of green jobs and such
like so
it it and it's still frankly a little
bit unclear what you know there's 1.1
billion dollars allocated to a green
jobs scheme
uh anticipating 11 000 jobs being
created out of it
i know that's a hundred thousand dollars
a job um a job creation is expensive um
uh but but beyond that we uh have yet to
see
and it's it's an observation not a
criticism because it's
it's moving pretty fast uh but we've yet
to see how that might be taken advantage
of and appropriate in this district
council williams followed by council
duty
thank you i can see the problems we're
going to have with um a wee bit of the
social
climate and to me i think it's our duty
to be forwarding on to these social
agencies that support people around
the next biggest thing is going to be
the financial help that businesses are
going to need and
um
the
it is here the rut that the um
um
the people are going to get into here
how on this project are we actually
going to help that going forward without
causing
us uh spending a lot of money and making
a big bureaucratic nightmare and
actually causing rates to increase
while trying to help um some of these
businesses
a couple of quick comments and it's a
big question
on the one hand look there is practical
advisory help that enc has been securing
for several weeks now and continues to
do that
uh and and it's an observation not a
criticism of that but that is helping
businesses determine whether they have a
future or not and and uh
and we are genuinely all a bit uncertain
as to how it's going to play out when
the wage subsidy
that's currently untrained
uh ends and then the the narrower
subsidy for businesses that are
suffering 50 or more downturn in revenue
how that plays out as well so
it will be a watch and wait and see how
that goes but
that's the practical on the ground
assistance that is i'll say affordable
through the enterprise north canterbury
um
contract if you like that they have with
the council and they've been pretty
successful in leveraging other funding
to do that but that won't continue
forever either
i think the other uh question that this
whole program will or series of programs
will raise is what's the right balance
between restraint
and the council's finances and budgeting
and expansion and
i'll use an example
so
an economist
shamabil jacob says to us that
if you took a million dollars of
reduction in rates
that has a jobs equivalent and this is a
broad average okay so it's a very broad
assessment that that might assist
saving or generating about eight and a
half jobs
if if local authorities bore
a million dollars in debt
for their capital program
and for the waimakariri district council
a million dollars in debt would fund
about 14 million dollars in capital
that has a jobs uh outcome of about 155
jobs
now those assessments are extremely
coarse
of course it's never it's it's the
mythical average but
uh that's that's that's about ninety
thousand dollars a job
and as i mentioned earlier there's about
you know eleven thousand jobs out of one
point one billion in green jobs is about
a hundred thousand dollars in jobs so
it's really expensive to create jobs
um
but that that is a is a
a weighing up that needs to be done out
of fiscal constraint by the council
and expansion in its program
and i guess we're not recommending that
you go out and spend money for the sake
of spending it i think we all want to
see what the color of the government's
money is through
the shovel ready projects and whatever
else we can get to land in this district
but if things get really grim
in the jobs market then
at what point does the council need to
wrestle with what's how does that strike
the right balance between restraint
because it's eventually got to be paid
for even if it is debt
and expansion to
buffer the worst excesses of what could
be a severe and protracted recession and
we just don't know right now how that's
going to play out
long answer i'm sorry but it is a moving
feast at the moment
the question
the answer quite didn't answer my actual
question i realized
the enterprise north canada side may um
help the um
the business side but here
if we're creating and spending half a
million dollars
on a bureaucratic site how's that side
of it going to help
that
that was my question
i'll try again briefly uh so at the
moment we don't have any resourcing to
implement um the design and implement a
recovery plan
we're doing it and simon's doing his day
job and then
uh being needed needing to spend time as
with others through the core recovery
group
so
there are other things that that that
are within our work programs that we're
budgeted to deliver
so
uh if we're gonna spend time on the
recovery plan then we need to do some
back filling of that other work
uh that has already been subject to
financial restraint
so
it
if if you don't want us to
work up a recovery plan that's a call
that you
can reasonably make
but it has a cost associated with it
council duty
thank you
it's very interesting reading your
programs of bee going through for your
recovery um the strategy in planning
um this liv
work ymca shop local how has that been
how effective has that been in promoting
our shops in our three towns or
workwise
so look that that's an initiative that
we think is a candidate program
project worthy of consideration
and that's kind of got two sides to it
it's about supporting your local supply
chain by wherever practical buying local
and uh and that may well be a question
that is
legitimately asked of the council about
giving preference to local suppliers
and what is a tolerable level or not
of um
of a financial consequence that it's
prepared to make to do that
and i'm not recommending that i'm just
saying that's a question that has
already been asked
but it's also about supporting your
local
shops and hospitality outlets
our view is if if there isn't a strong
support for such a program out of the
respective promotions associations
across our our main towns then that's
probably not a project that
is viable from our point of view and we
say that because a
we don't have staff time available
unless we budget more to do that to mana
design manage and implement that program
and the
enterprise north canterbury are more
than over committed at the moment in
practical business support to businesses
uh so in our view and it's not a
it's it's a discussion that we would
want to have and need to have with the
promotions associations if they aren't
behind that
then um
we can't force it on them and we
wouldn't seek to
implement that without their strong
involvement and support
this is not a question but it is working
well
counselor i can see your question
thank you mr mine's around uh back to
the duplication exactly what's just been
explained is something that concerns me
and uh wouldn't mind an answer for the
government is driving a local shop local
uh campaign that's all over your
televisions all over every bit of
communication that we have at the
present time it seems to be a focus
within what we're doing and while i'm
not saying we shouldn't have the
discussion that's not what i'm saying
i'm really concerned that what we have
in here is actually to
really strongly duplicated by what's
already happening by civil central
government
and that example i just around that
question
of that duplication that is a really
good example that we already gonna start
it if we're starting this conversation
with that you know
i mean what's your view on that
well i i absolutely agree with you we
need to kick the tires on it is is it
happening to what degree is it happening
can it carry on happening because it's
going to be needed for a period of time
um uh
i don't i you know just using that
example i don't think there is a central
government agency who's actually funding
or implementing a shop local campaign up
and down the country there's a lot of
kind of
advertising going on but that's
generic and across new zealand
the question is about
is there a merit or not and it's a
question to be answered counselor i
agree
in a tailor-made customized
program of that nature project of that
nature for the main centres in
in waimakariri district and we we've
just highlighted it on a long list and
we don't know the answer to that yet we
need to do some tyre kicking over the
next few weeks and bring that back to
you in july for you to decide whether
that's uh
still on the list
further questions
i've got the recommendation um i would
like to move this if it's right this
afternoon councillor bar that's
indicated that she's
appeared to second
so just in moving um i'd like to say
firstly um thank you to mr hart uh and
mr markham there's been a lot of work
going on behind the scenes
uh talking with various businesses and
community organizations to bring us
forward
the start of this journey really and
we've we've had a workshop where we've
discussed this
council's not the soul
is not going to have all the answers in
this space and i think that's been
clearly indicated through questions and
even
freely through our staff you know the
social
side of the equation
is very important and council williams
were asked a very good question in that
space but it's working with the social
service agencies it's working with work
and income who are part of this
grouping that's already existing
to get them involved and
coming up with the solutions if we need
to be activating a social
uh recovery aspect that's something we
can look at at a later stage at the
moment the most pressing item
well firstly as a counselor we needed to
signal to our community where we stood
on rates
we did that last week
and that gave an albeit that's going to
come back and be endorsed officially by
the council
on the 16th but sending that message was
really important
first time i've actually had people stop
me on the street and say thank you for
what your council's done
thank you to your staff for listening to
us
and these are people that i would have
thought were reasonably well healed
actually that wanted an indication from
the council that it was prepared to do
something to acknowledge the
circumstances that were in
so indicating 1.5 percent actually send
a fairly strong message to a lot of
people who feedback to us that they're
appreciative that the council has
listened and is acknowledging that we're
in a time of hardship it's not saying
that we have the answers for the future
we've got a lot of work to do in that
space as was indicated last week
but now is about forming
a recovery plan and getting that
underway work's been started in that
space
but i think that the slogan before
better than before i
don't mind that slogan
as well as um coming up with the the
economic recovery advisory group i think
that's a very good initiative and we'll
have to
think about who a party to that and
we'll bring that back here as as was
said
um enterprise north canterbury have been
getting on with work they've been
providing support to a lot of businesses
that have needed cash flow advice and
are doing a really good job in that
space
and that's the feedback i've had from a
number of businesses that have been
struggling
and that needed that advice partnering
with accounting firms to get them that
practical support that they've needed
at the moment a lot of the effects that
are going on
are actually masked by the wage
subsidies but everyone says to me that
feeds back so we don't actually know
what the true effect is at the moment
because it's sort of masked by that i
hope it's not as bad as anticipated
uh i really do and we i was told in the
local cafe that they'll find out the
outcome of bunnings today
um so i'm hoping that that's that they
revise their decision and that
we who will know but those sort of
things happening in our community are
important signals uh when when major
retailers move away it's not it's not
something we want to see happen and our
local small businesses don't want to see
them struggling either they've been
through a lot
so
council's partners is to coordinate to
show a lead where we need to to advocate
but we're not going to have all the
answers half 500 000 up i should say to
our staff it's up to 500 000
it's not a free for all um and that will
need some good um rationale put in that
as to whether or not we we expend that
money but i'm supportive of that because
you can't have a plan without having
some money to implement some initiative
so
look this is the start of the journey
thank you to our staff for what they've
done i think the questioning is
indicating that you know we've all got
some some concerns about it we need to
know where government's at in this space
we're seeing some trickle effect of of
their decision making at this stage but
they've got a 20 billion dollar fund set
aside we're not sure exactly where
that's going to be totally invested yet
and we've indicated our shovel ready
projects they've gone through to stage
two hopefully they go through further we
will see but look this is the start of
it and i'm fully prepared to support it
and thank to the staff for the work
they've done councilman
yes thank you the mayor is absolutely
correct and that we we're this is a
coordination role that we're taking it's
showing leadership to our district
locally and it's using our local
knowledge to get the best results for
people in our district
when it comes to economic development if
we don't do it other councils near us
will
and it's a matter of us leveraging the
maximum benefit we can get for our
ratepayers of whatever funding is
available during the recovery period
we're going to need private investment
it's certainly not going to be something
that's put all on rate payers and we're
fully aware of that and the need to keep
costs down we're going to have to
balance that throughout our discussions
but to me the absolute most important
thing is the community engagement side
and we saw that in the earthquake if
people knew something was happening they
were far more willing to come along with
us even if it was a bad thing and then
to actually be kept in the dark and we
have to step up in that area and the
recovery plan will be part of that it'll
be about forming partnerships as you've
noted and but most importantly to take
the community with us which includes
all elected members or community board
or staff and all of our residents
councillor atkinson followed by
councillor williams
thank you mr mayor because i support
this
around my questioning you will have
heard my concern and that is duplication
we did that through the earthquake
there's been duplication generally
generally not on our side we would start
something the government would come
along with exactly the same scheme and
decide that they should do that as well
um so i'm not suggesting that we do the
duplication what i'm concerned about is
that it happens uh half a million
dollars in the grand scheme of the
disaster we have in front of us is not a
lot of money
but
when it becomes rate payers money of
half a million dollars or up to a
million dollars by the time you do your
second third trench whatever that may be
you're starting to talk serious money
when you put that into the country's
money it's actually a little different
instead of it costing everybody you know
a dollar a week it costs you uh five
cents a week when it's the government's
money so that duplication does concern
me and and it's something that i will
certainly be keeping an eye on because
we have had that before and i just don't
want to see it again but enc have worked
well with uh
with our businesses beforehand i think
it was for if my memory serves me right
which is probably not something that
happens often 120 uh businesses in the
service industry just in cairo alone
that can attribute part of their savior
to the fact that they were involved in
the nc programs
after the earthquake and brought them
together to talk to each other just to
make sure that they they could survive
and get through and find out from each
other what was happening in their own
backyards and and that was been a
beneficial to all of them i sometimes
wonder whether we take these things too
far
and
we actually
push too far when it's actually about
communication
and collaboration as opposed to actually
getting out there and doing things when
other people in all of these other
industries are making it happen but
that's a question you'll always have and
the proofs and the pudding you never
know until you get halfway through that
or to the end of that whether that's the
right question or the wrong question if
you like so we we've done this before
it's been a different circumstance and
you've heard me say it before this is a
different disaster because it doesn't
matter where in the world you go to you
can't get away from it so you know we do
need to take a lead in this and we need
to be there but i just want to reiterate
the duplication and the fact that the
lead agency and this is the government
we need to be in there and make sure
we're doing the right things but the
government is the lead agency
council williams
yes while i support what we're doing in
principle i think um council acts and
spot on
we don't want to create a duplication of
things
i believe enterprise north canterbury uh
the expert said it we don't want to
duplicate and um
try to um
have two um shots at the um we're better
off too if they can't get government
funding for the extra bit of it well
maybe we're better off to shovel a wee
bit of funding
for them because they are the experts on
it rather than us trying to um do
something we are already working with
their social agencies around we've got
some really really good social agencies
in
waimakariri i think for me i think
there's about 70 different um
small organizations and some of them are
working very well they are going to be
needed and we are already working i just
i just see half a million dollars of
rate past money getting
swallowed up in a bit of bureaucratic
stuff and it doesn't get
to the places where it needed where we
might be able to give a portion of that
500 000 to
enterprise north canterbury can't get
that give them a portion they can do far
better
with that kind of money than what we can
do with um the duplication and it may be
happened we may have to pour away but
into some of the social service
networks we've got here as well they are
the experts of that as well
um i just don't want us to take a
leading role when the government is the
leading role on it and they will be
supporting
all those agencies but we are
they've got a lot more money than we've
got and um
you know i just think we've just got to
make sure we don't have a bureaucratic
network and um
cost the rate pass a lot of extra money
where it's not necessary
thank you council blacking
thank you mr may i can be brief the last
two speakers have covered some good
salient points um i'm just a little
concerned about the just duplication
thing where we're going if we're going
down the money route um
as a support mechanism then enc as paul
has just said is there up and running
with a proven track record we ought to
just be literally giving them the
dollars and saying you spend it um and i
and and after pro of that i don't think
we've allocated enough money into this
into the recovery scheme as i as i
mentioned last week uh if we're going
down the psychosocial support route
again tessa's empire is there with a
proven record knows exactly what to do
it is already up and doing it so i'm
just worried that we're going to we're
going to be careful we don't reinvent
the wheel internally i appreciate
there's a there's a problem with what
government and us but just be careful
internally that we're not we're not
getting down too far down the
duplication road um i look forward to
seeing some
boots on the ground
progress with this committee and
actually what we're going to what are we
going to be actually doing uh real hard
facts you know at the moment i'll steal
nikki's comment from last year we're a
bit of white hat and no cattle
cast the i hope l hasn't stolen your uh
your thunderberry
that's a big hat and no kettle but
that's right close enough
um look
you know that
back it up
i'm still thinking about big hats and
cattle um like this this council's
need to to to balance our communities
needs now with with the needs of the
future community um you know this this
is our
this is our council's
earthquake moment right all over again
you know we have to to balance the here
and now with with the future and we need
to get that right i commend the
comprehensive approach of of this plan
at a grassroots level because you know
there's a big difference between central
government saying
buy a local and
us here at grassroots level saying buy
from abc on high street or william
street
because we know what we have here and
who we have here and again i echo the
sentiments that enc is um a really
great organization to handle that but
again grassroots is important and on the
same token looking at the fantastic work
that tess's community team has done i've
seen it firsthand i've sat in her
community welfare meetings
again there's a big difference in a
central government saying oh yes we're
going to put
resources and to msd et cetera and us
knowing what our people need right here
right now on the ground
so i absolutely stand behind what you're
looking to achieve here and
and again yes of course proceed with
caution with
duplication but
grassroots knowledge cannot be
overlooked and underestimated so
hats off little hat
to you guys thank you i support this
thank you mr mayor
um
probably a question that i that i would
have for
the two simons um
do you see that this new um role would
would be something that would be in
addition or complementary to what we
already have i see that enterprise north
canterbury's role will be to
to um
from my experience will be to
visit waimakariri to promote shop
locally
and i see the government's role in doing
bigger things but i see the role that
you're looking at doing is maybe
something that's complementary but is
looking after
the bigger picture or the
the
shovel really projects that might
come about
and help project um
help
get those underway and organize them
alongside
do i need to have a question
[Laughter]
all right um i just would like
clarification that you see
um this role this new role as being
something that is is complementary to
what we have in place right now
thank you
a quick comment and then maybe simon
martin might have some comments too
i think if you look through the six
programs and the 27 projects there there
is a range of things that certainly e
and c would want to lead and and are
highly involved in
absolutely take the point that we don't
want to duplicate anything that we have
an existing network or agency doing and
or that the government might do on our
behalf albeit at a much higher level
potentially
there is quite a significant role i
think for council on the coordination
and leadership of this recovery and
there are there is also a series of
programs and projects within that plan
that are council
capital funded or council projects in
their own right
so i think uh the recovery role that we
probably have is twofold in my mind one
is about leadership and coordination of
the response and the recovery for our
district by the aid the many agencies
that will be involved in that recovery
and then monitoring how that is going
and ensuring there is no duplication and
partly coordination and leadership helps
to eliminate uh duplication so i think
that's one important role and then the
other important role is the delivery of
anything that council has specifically
that it wants to deliver towards
recovery and some of those projects are
looking at our capital program the
shovel ready projects um leading of the
review of certain strategies that may
aid guide decision making over the
longer terms we recover so i think those
are some of my initial comments
did you wish to speak now castle
you can't speak if you'd like to
you okay
council duty
thank you
and i'm just once again back on my shop
local promotion i and i know that this
has been done by
government but i really don't want to
see that ever
lose its momentum end because it's
working well already um i just noticed
in oxford yesterday just how busy they
are
up there with people coming out from
christchurch and buying and and being
part of it
and i just think this is one thing that
we really do need to just keep pushing
because the more people we have out here
looking after our businesses more
businesses will survive
and work
any further speakers
just in right of reply um i i think
there's been some good comment come
through debate
i don't personally want to see
duplication and actually from our staff
neither do they from the comments that
they're talking of
someone's got to take a lead in this
space and logically it should be council
but it's partnering with other
organizations and importantly in the
terms of reference which is on page 67
enterprise north canterbury are there
in the terms of reference as a partner
in this exercise
before any rate payer spending is um
was spent uh or or expended there will
need to be a good case and that will
require council sign off so the sum of
money that was set aside was just set
aside there's no there's no decision
being made on how that will be expanded
it is simply set aside on the basis that
we need to have something there in order
to support initiatives which may come
out of this but it will require this
council sign off before it is spent and
there will need to be a good case as
there is in any instance where we are
putting aside rate payer investment
i i endorse um
the comments around shop local i've long
held that view
um
but i i do think that it's important who
leads that exercise and i know
enterprise north canterbury from a
discussion i had with heather the other
day they are looking at that very topic
at the moment
and my understanding is they're looking
at a new promotion to take a lead in
that space and they are the right
organisation to lead that
supported by our council of course but
supported by all the other partners and
businesses
retailers
promotions associations they've all got
to buy into this because there needs to
be a concerted effort that's got the
same message for it to work and building
on where the government's at and in the
space and if you only have to drive into
town to see big big slogan and big
billboards talking about buying and
shopping local that's everywhere at the
moment so it's i think i think our
public get that message um you only have
to be out in their towns to see that
happening over the various weekends or
during the day rengar is very busy
during the day
that i've noticed i certainly heard
anecdotally from retailers in kaiapoi
that they're doing
doing okay as well not doing as well as
they were before but the same is here
so right across our district um that
message is getting through but this is
start of the process
start putting in place uh
the
um
a recovery plan being developed
developing that
and it will be with our endorsement and
our buy-in going forward so thank you to
our staff they've done pulling this
together we appreciate it
and i'll put the recommendation
7.2
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
to clear that carry thank you simon and
simon
[Applause]
all right we now come to um
further reports just to let you know
sophie's sophie's having some issues
connecting in
so jared's i'm going to
look at
looking after that report when he comes
through to deal with item 8.7 so we'll
deal with that at the same time
all right so reports 8.1
uh it's the
there's a number of reports that have
ordinarily gone to audit so they've come
here okay so the first is the 8.1
non-financial performance measures
helene
that's pages 69 to 87 everyone
hello
so the reports for the first of january
to 31st march this year
so
unfortunately we're pretty much on a par
with quarter three last year which is
good
covert 19 only really just hit before
this quarter finished
and it did affect the results of four of
the measures that are that weren't
achieved but overall we did a
pretty good job everyone managed to do
their reporting during lockdown and um
get the report together so any questions
any questions of a name
count councilor barna followed by
council blacking
um helene i just wondered about the
mahinga kai area
that's been
has this is this report in the future
going to reflect the changes to the long
term
changes to the annual plane that we made
in the budgets
perhaps mr palmer could assist
duncan has indicated that some of these
projects have been pushed back
and there will be some changes for the
annual plan long-term plan yes yeah
thanks celina page 72 that that
essay you've written there about the
leakage factor um
you've said there that the
confidence in the data is relatively low
and this goes on to say that um until a
cost-effective and accurate alternative
to night testing is established blah
blah blah and then the last line says a
detailed report on the on the on the
latest leakage assessment will be
brought to you in our what is the point
of bringing a detailed report when
you've just admitted that the data is
useless to put for want of a better word
perhaps i might be perhaps perhaps i
might be um better uh placed so um
certainly we do have some concerns about
the level of ionized infiltration
that's inflow and infiltration ionize
that is occurring in the
chiropodist system
and
trying to track that down is something
which we actually considered this
morning a management team and have
approved a
a contract for
uh the piracy sorry the parakeet street
uh the praki catchment being subject to
an assessment actually using a different
methodology than we've used in the past
which has often been a house to house
survey
there's been a methodology adapted or
developed and applied across the country
where you actually
install temperature sensors throughout
part of the network and you can actually
detect changes in temperature of where
inflow is coming from and so that is
actually something that we're going to
use in
the piracy catchment to try and
understand where our inflow and
infiltration is occurring and tracking
that down further so that is that is a
change that we're taking but we've
certainly
certainly got problems in that part of
our you know
post earthquake we still have issues
that
we definitely need to be addressing i
and i because the capacity of the
system
can't be expanded affordably to actually
cater with the flows that are that we're
seeing or anticipating
further questions
we have a recommendation some are
prepared to move
moved by council williams did you put
your hand up you'd have now um
second did
councillor blackie council williams did
you wish to say anything
council blackie
any further speakers council stewart
thank you mr mayor um i certainly
welcome uh any further reporting
and whatever system seems to be more
appropriate
than the one
we have i mean i was astounded when we
had a report
a couple of years ago
that had that figure of 29
leakage and some schemes far higher
than that
i also note on page 73 which
i find also
rather concerning is the um we have a
target of less than 450 litres
of drinking water per day per resident
and our result is 624 liters
and i
i'm concerned about that i don't know
whether all
this is a function of
the
methodology that is faulty um in
measuring uh drinking water but
perhaps um mr palmer could comment on
that but
um
if that's not the case
what are we doing to address
the fact that that must be
[Music]
fifty percent getting on for fifty
percent over um
what we would um uh targeting for
drinking water consumption
well question and
expressing concern yes
i'm
clear on the question i'm
struggling with my system to be able to
expand the page that i'm looking at with
the detail that talks about
water supply because that is the average
for the third quarter
and what i was
as you were speaking interested to try
and ascertain if i could what the
what what the year-to-date average is uh
noting that the third quarter is our
summer season so
i'm and i'm hoping
and it's a hope rather than a uh
that that may reflect um
a higher irrigation use but i am not
i'm struggling to actually find the in
our
associated um
work
yeah i'll
have a look at that
just endorsing the need to get on top of
this leakage whether in fact it is um
true or not we need some clarification
and of course
the only really real way to get a handle
on it is to install meters
which
is another another entire debate but um
uh the information that we have to hand
and have had in the past is that um we
have huge leakage from
uh our various water supply systems and
i for one
need to be assured that
is the methodology as mr palmer has
indicated slightly uh is suspect and if
so let's fix it so that we do get some
accurate
data and if it
if it is accurate
then my god we need to address it very
quickly
thank you
just to say that the comment uh in the
report the detail does
anticipate and it's in accordance with
other years the higher demand in the
third quarter and
with a winter month reduction occurring
we should
be
it will be closer to achieving uh the
target on an annualized basis
a few of this
further speakers
okay
write reply yeah
if you would like to
put that all those in favor please say
aye
contrary to clear that carry thanks
tonight
are you able to reconnect into the
technology there yeah
okay
we'll continue um
but uh if you've got a problem let us
know we can get um emmy or someone down
to
sandra's
out of the zoom
all right
all right hold on that's right i was
just looking to see if you're ready so
first it's wrapped now to item 8.2 pages
88 to 97. mr markham
thank you mr mayor so uh
this
is a report that uh in ordinary times
would have gone through to audit and
risk committee in terms of providing the
opportunity to comment on
the draft soi for those members of audit
and risk you'll recall
that
at the meeting of a r committee just
before the lockdown
a number of enc board members and the
chief executive
gave quite an extensive briefing uh at
that meeting around
um the uh scoping of enc activities and
just to jog your memories because it is
a while back now remember they
uh showcased the um uh waimakariri story
uh video that
uh is in preparation as part of district
marketing
uh
so uh this is about uh allow i guess
an opportunity to provide any final
feedback to the board before they
finalize the
statement of intent
that has been reviewed in the context of
covid so it addresses the scope of
enterprise north canterbury's activity
it doesn't
uh address the amount and that's the
issue that would need to be
considered at our view in the context of
a recovery plan and
um i i'll
you know the comments in a in the
earlier report around the recovery plan
are higher are relevant in the in the
sense of uh
depending upon the scope and scale of
government funding and how that plays
out
is is it appropriate or not
for
the council to
provide additional funding to enterprise
north canterbury to upsize some of their
programs at the moment
uh their budget is as it was
actually it's diminished because the
inflation adjustment has been removed
from their budget so it is it is no more
than uh what was foreshadowed in the
original draft annual plan
i'm happy to seek to answer any of your
questions
thank you mr markham questions
so counselor um
sorry
thank you mr markham um
just wondering obviously a lot of the
interpersonal canterbury programs have a
pay-as-you-go type element to them for
businesses who participate has there
been any thought given to having some
sort of funds set up to assist
businesses
who
would normally contribute or but can no
longer or those who may wish to
contribute in the future
look i think that would be one of the
options worth considering and you may
see a number of councils have
established those kind of contestable
funds
for uh struggling uh businesses to apply
for
assistance outside of the structures of
formal
or ordinary support programs ordinarily
the business support
they access new zealand
trade and enterprise money
that helps fund provision professional
advice to the business to help them with
their cash flow forecasting and such
like
and then they're able to turn on
business business mentors that still
requires the uh the
business that may well be in significant
difficulty um to raise some money and
invest some cost in in that and uh they
may not be in that position to do that
uh having said that uh look
if your business is in that position
then uh and i know it's incredibly easy
for me as a public sector employee to
say but if your business is in that
position then the reality might be the
best thing is to wind the business up
and and not continue to try and make uh
make it work in very very difficult
market circumstances um
but but that's that's something that
they wrestle with actually every day and
through all of those 705 assessments
they've done there are a number of
businesses that are in that very
difficult position
just the second question i had was
how appropriate do you think it is to
have the business awards next year
considering we're going into a recession
and is that something the board may
discuss further
i'm imagining like um
many
events there is uh
it's
put forward to 2021
it will get continuously monitored um
probably the big one and that and that
list is the olympics and frankly you
know that's looking pretty unlikely but
they're not going to give up on that now
so i'm
i'm sensing that will be a watching
brief the other side to it is uh
by the time the 2021 awards come along
stadium waimakariri is open
that's a real opportunity to showcase
business in this district and uh i think
that's a balancing act to be struck
between
um the sort of restraint that we're all
having to
uh become familiar with but also
when do you want to shout it
shout out that you've got some great
businesses in this district and you want
to celebrate that that success and and
um so that that that i'm sure is under
the uh watching brief of the board
further questions
i've got a recommendation counselor
atkinson's moving seconded by
council duty do you speak counts right
concern
yes mr thank you um
you look this is an agency that does
well in our district
and uh
when the times get tough the tough get
going and they're one of those people in
the agency that does exactly that and
you heard in that previous report about
120 service businesses that um
that i talked about that uh
i've spoken to a few of them who
attribute themselves the tribute enc to
the success of them still being in
business
um after the after the earthquake
interesting the um council bonnie and
the
business awards that's actually an
interesting one because i remember the
first business awards after the
earthquake and they were postponed at
that time and put forward
i remember businesses talking about the
fact that uh which had never been
postponed because those that had done
what they'd done through that time and
and survived and actually got up and got
going it was actually the best thing
that they went to
at that point so and that'll be always
an arguable point what do you do you
know
which way do you go and that's a
decision for enc to make
but we took some years to get to an esoi
like this
and get
uh enc into a place that we all
understood what everybody was doing you
know
and and i think we've done that we keep
refining it we keep going and we keep
making sure that each other knows what
each other is doing in my view i think
he and c do a damn fine job in this in
this district um and they have a board
which is which is
um has a cross section of people on it
that actually give very good advice
to them um and uh and they follow that
advice uh led by a team that clearly are
successful in what they do they seem to
employ their teams well and they seem to
execute the business which is given to
them well
and for that i hope that everybody
around the table will support this going
through
oh sorry
thank you councillor atkinson seconded
by council do you wish to speak
no actual counseling has
all i'd like to say is just definitely
we
very much promote this enterprise north
canterbury and um help it by generating
a bit more capital to get them really
moving on this
area that we're going through at the
moment that needs serious help
council williams followed by council
banner
whilst i haven't always been a fully um
supporter of enterprise north canterbury
and questions um
the funding they get from the rate
powers and the accounts and what have
you i think this is the time where it's
very important for enterprise north
canterbury to actually shine and thrust
as a council to be proud of them
to um stand up and be counted and i
think they will need to be standing up
and be counted because
um our community is going to need them
to
help
not
in the business side of it but it's a
flow on to the the normal workers that
um in our community and um i'm hoping in
12 months time
two years time we can all say wow that's
the best thing we've ever supported in
this area so um very important i think
at this particular stage so
i think they will shine
thank you
yes i've certainly heard absolutely
glowing reports about what enc have been
doing through the covert emergency and i
particularly want to acknowledge miles
dalton who's just been working so hard
and there's another person who's
contracted and to help
with businesses and cash flow and
they've been brilliant at bringing these
partnerships together with financial
services and to try and keep these
businesses afloat so
first of all want to acknowledge the
sterling work that's been done through
this very very difficult time
but as we've seen before it's a marathon
it's not a sprint and the major effect
is going to be felt over the next
year or even more than one year
we are in for a global recession and
that will impact on many businesses
local
national and we will see a lot of
changes during that time like
we're not sure who will get through it
and we're not sure who won't
um the only factors we are going to see
change
the only reason i really brought up the
business awards is i just don't want to
be accused of a let them eat cake
scenario where um some businesses are
there celebrating buying expensive
tickets for a wonderful dinner and an
absolutely brilliant night out
whereas some businesses now can't afford
to actually be at that event so we've
just got to be mindful that some people
are going to be in a very um difficult
situation and that that awards may have
to be sort of
perhaps reviewed in that light and so
that we don't we make sure that we're
not appearing elitist we're not
appearing to pick favorites that we're
very much um about all the businesses in
waimakariri and that's what who enc
works for so but going forward i'm sure
the board will discuss that we don't
know what situation we're going to be in
2021 it's anyone's guess at this stage
so i look forward to seeing further
reports on what's going to be done in
the future
thank you uh next council award followed
by council stuart
thank you mr mayor
i just want i cannot under emphasize how
important enterprise north canterbury is
and what great value
that we get out of our investment in
them
and i i'm sure that most people don't
really understand
exactly as an independent arm of our
district
that how they can
um
get extra funding which the council
cannot apply for they they really work
really really hard to make important
things happen and get extra funding and
um
that's what really
drives them is the extra funding outside
of what we we contribute from the
ratepayers so they're really very good
value and um
i can't say enough
how important they are as far as the
business awards i think that 21 2021
will be a wonderful opportunity
to showcase our new stadium
um
and i'm sure that
certainly there'll be no restrictions of
numbers so that'll be a great plus and
everybody will be able to enjoy it thank
you
thank you council stuart
thank you mr mayor um
a question first about the market view
data and
how is that going to be married into
the reporting of all these initiatives
in what enc is doing um what our
recovery plan will yield and we we've
got a benchmark pre-covered which will
be the market view data so enlighten us
all about how that's going to be
reported presumably to audit and risk
and it will give us that presumably the
ability to see what well first of all
see what's happening but also see where
the needs are and where we can target
thank you
so um
it's
timely so at the moment we're tracking
towards the 21st of july audit and risk
committee to do the presentation that
we might have otherwise done before uh
but with the program was interrupted by
the lockdown so and uh we are um
i won't go into the details but got
better data on around employment now
we've got
census results coming through etc so
that would be when we would have an
opportunity to give you a high uh
an update and an overview of how
employment's tracking um
how expenditure is tracking
um happy happy to uh to be doing that at
the at the july count um ordered a risk
committee meeting
did you speak answers to it
no you're just a question yep
further speakers
write a reply counselor atkinson
i'd rather reply so i'll put the
recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
to clear that carried
thank you mr margaret
just wait for a couple of minutes while
we're just the next staff member comes
thank you
okay so we now come to 8.3 pages 98 to
125 the outcomes of the council's health
and safety risk register review
um
charlotte and pace of this
charlotte so um
this this here only works one at a time
so we click off in between questions etc
so thank you
good afternoon mr mayor councillors um
as mentioned i'm here on behalf of liz
ashton to present to you the outcomes of
the wdc health and safety risk register
for march um this would have ordinarily
been presented to the audit and risk
committee previously but obviously we've
had delays given the um covert 19
situation
um
it does present this is now the seventh
review so i have presented this
previously to
audit and risk
including the health and safety risk
register and associated action plan for
any high risk or high consequence
actions
i will take the report as having been
read however just wanted to raise a
couple of key points
to bring to your attention
as noted in the recommendations we have
recently trans transitioned the risk
register across to the pro-map risk and
compliance module that you will have
seen earlier today the
covert 19 risk register it was in that
format
so hopefully we'll have given you some
level of familiarity of how that looks
that has also meant therefore that there
has been a change in rating methodology
so we do have
a variance in
risk ratings although they have been
the same likelihood and consequence
because they've the
health and safety risk register is now
aligned with the wdc risk management
framework methodology
so therefore you will see that
difference in risk rating scores
um
there have been no significant changes
in those risk assessments during this
time
however there has been a significant
improvement in the quality of the
descriptors
and control measures for each of those
risks as they have been transferred
across to that
risk and compliance module
um and included in 4.2 you will have
seen that we have the top 20 health and
safety risks available to you for your
reference do i have any questions
thank you
charlotte just
i think just actually what you were
speaking on
it says the change
in the 4.3 the change in rating
methodology does not reflect
any change
in operational practices
if we take one of those which we had in
2019 as high and then we swap
we've put in a further
19 sorry
19 20
21 to high how can we say that makes no
difference or change to the operation
because if the ratings gone up then what
you have to do to mitigate that must go
up which means people must have to make
an adjustment to how they operate to
make these things happen
is
if i got my assumption totally wrong or
is that
sorry
perhaps so yeah yeah
so in chain
in changing the rating structure
and what's triggered so many to be high
and when you look down the list there's
a lot that are now scored at 200 points
which under the revised framework
just catches it under a high banner
which
is
there
the typical scenario of that is
um
the
uh the consequence of the event
occurring is
um deemed high and that might be
serious injury or death
at the moment the likelihood sitting it
and as it was previously is unlikely now
that translates to a score of
2 in the likelihood scale and
100 in the in the consequence scale
which gives you a score of 200. i i
think one of the things that we'll
reflect on is are they genuinely
um
unlikely or are they rare and that might
be something that we can reflect on
further because i don't think we've
quite got the transition right in terms
of
under our previous arrangement
there would have been essentially no
change in our risk assessment if it had
been if we'd used our old
what was called the five by five scale
so you had a consequence of somewhere
between one and five and a likelihood of
somewhere between one and five
and the way that that
frame was put together changed our
changed our view of the risk
so
i think
what this has done in my mind has just
given will give us pause
to think about have we just got that
mix quite right the underlying risks and
mitigations don't necessarily change but
if if we thought
in a rating scale and this is where we
need to reflect further if if an event
is likely to cause serious injury or
death
and we have have our rating somewhere
between
rare unlikely
likely probable and almost certain as
the five things if we've got things that
are like in the unlikely category then
perhaps we should be doing more to try
and reduce that
uh risk which is your point about surely
shouldn't we be doing more but i'm not
sure we should be doing more we might
just need we we first need to just have
a look at our
how that scale is working because it it
doesn't feel quite right to me to be
honest
if i make
clarifying this come here
well while your answers are helpful one
two to the way i'm thinking but it says
here
that
does not reflect any change in
operational practices now if we have
probable likely and unlikely if it's
likely then there are changes to people
on the ground that they must make
to mitigate likely as opposed to
unlikely now if we've jumped from
having one of those to now 22 that makes
an absolute massive difference does it
not to the people on the ground who are
actually carrying out the exercise might
not on the paper but certainly doesn't
be setting up a work site
and and i think that's a fair question
councillor some of them though we would
argue you know
as an example one of them is around
people driving using our fleet and
having an accident the potential
consequence could be serious
serious injury or death albeit touch
wood and more than touch wood good
practice and management we haven't had
that scenario unfold yet um
we've looked at that and at the moment
we honestly can't think of anything more
we can do and that to what we're
currently doing to further reduce
the likelihood maybe we need to
review our risk
rating on that but there's probably not
many things we can do in terms of either
our fleet or driver training or apart
from doing less kilometers which we
typically are doing less of those being
on the road less
um
so one of the reasons why it says it
doesn't reflect any change in
operational practices or decrease in
control measure effectiveness is that
what we've basically done is we've taken
all of our prior operational practices
and control measures and we've
translated them across into a slightly
different risk rating methodology um
what that has probably given us pause to
do as jim was mentioning is actually
check whether or not where previously
the the rating methodology gave us a lot
of lows and mediums um we probably now
need to go back and ask ourselves the
question whether or not we have been
against the new rating methodology
whether we are rating them accurately um
we do have a lot of
uh already quite effective control
measures in place and those are sort of
within the the overall risk register
that you have in the report um
and i think probably what we as a
and the management needed to team need
to do is actually sit back and reflect
and say and as jim said is ask the
question so with the new rating
methodology should we be saying
something as unlikely or is it rare to
drop it down that that level um
in terms of everything else everything
else has remained the same
so um all that all that change reflects
is simply an alignment with a new rating
methodology
so
in the interim while you're reflecting
what risk does that put us
put us at with 21 high
risks now as opposed to one
until such time as we've reflected
so in terms as it says in the report it
hasn't changed our operational practice
so the the years of work that we have
put in to reduce those risks
as to as low as is reasonably
practicable still remains in place
nothing has changed operationally on the
ground
so all of those control measures that we
have in place all of the procedures the
equipment the ppe the um plant that we
have
that we have put in place over that
period of time has not changed so um
so therefore this is about a rate rather
about a rating methodology rather than
then specifically about what is actually
happening on the ground
council williams
yes on page 101
um a fair contract the safety
requirements not adequate
the government gives
i think a
certain standards every business in new
zealand has to operate at
are we saying
that the government standards aren't
good enough and we should be lobbying
them to
upgrade their systems or are we putting
our
posts too high because it can't be
worked both ways um
it's a question it's a real interesting
good question
um are we leading
are we leading the safety standards and
should be lobbying the government to
higher standards or
um
our
current contractor management processes
are actually in
um alignment with the government
standards so basically the worksafe has
put out guidance in regards to managing
contractors and working
in partnership or
with an alignment with other companies
we've made sure that all of our
contractor management processes are
actually
aligned to and compliant with
their guidance
so yes they are leading the way
and we are ensuring that we are matching
that expectation
yeah the supplementary question then um
if we are in alignment with the um
government standards what they are
requiring all businesses to operate on
why won't we
why aren't we allowing some of the other
businesses to operate here because their
standards aren't high enough
when they already have to get to that
government level
so that's around us doing our due
diligence to ensure that we are
working with organizations that are
meeting those standards um so that's
part of our role as a pcbu is to ensure
that the people that we contract with
are matching the standards that are
expected
by
essentially through by worksafe and the
and the government so yes we are that's
that's part of our role
any further questions
sorry counselor blacky
followed by councillor um redmond thank
you
thanks
um page 120
under high
um
consequent risk boat operations practice
rescue plan what is that alluding to in
the context of our council
so our water unit uses um motorised
boats on the on the ponds and so
therefore just ensuring that they so
they have a boat operation standard
operating procedure they have a
maritime
licensing as well and then obviously
ensuring that for any high risk actions
that they're undertaking so we we would
do this for things like confined space
entry or working at heights but for boat
operations as well that they're just
practicing any drills that they need to
practice in terms of if there is if
there are any um
adverse outcomes
and does that apply that applies to any
council staff
or elector members or anybody on say the
river
in a boat
uh if you are operating a craft on the
river on council business then my
assumption is that yes that would be the
case so um i would have to get a better
understanding of exactly what the
operations were but um yes
regent thank you mr mayor i'm a little
bit confused
on the
change in
methodology
um i take it that the 14 low
risk
figure
is actually the same as now one
low
figure
so i just wondered are you going to
recalibrate
the
new
uh technique
so that we get something a little bit
more consistent as
mr palmer indicated before previously
low to medium had quite a heavy
weighting
and now we're medium to high
has a very high rating it doesn't look
as good as the old myth
method
method method
[Laughter]
it's like watching the bloopers um
yeah are you going to look at
recalibrating so
i mean i don't know what the answer is
here but it seems to me that we get two
different answers from the same
sort of
circumstances
sure and that's that's something that we
have flagged is that yes we will look at
at i suppose uh
the the calibration has happened so
we've we've switched over systems
and this was because
and this is what has happened in risk
asset risk management across the
organization people do it differently in
different areas so as an organization
what we are beginning to do is actually
start to use a single methodology and
that will mean that sometimes we get uh
outcomes that are a little bit of out of
out of kilter from the the previous
outcomes so risk management be it in
project management we'll be at in health
and safety management or be it in
corporate
we want to try and bring them all in
alignment with the same rating
methodology so that means that we are
going to get
hiccups like this and yes on the next
round of reviews we will be looking very
closely
and ensuring that those
those descriptors and ratings have been
fully interrogated to make sure that
they are as accurate it is as possible
yes
sorry
one
further comment from me is
the purpose of the risk assessment is
not only to understand you know to sort
of try and quantify the effect but it's
actually a prioritization mechanism so
where do we actually invest our energies
and that's actually a relative
comparison so what's our highest risk
thing for our business as opposed to
lower risk matters so this while it
it sort of has a
uh science around it per se
and helps us that the real purpose of
putting some risk assessment is to
actually understand where should we be
investing our effort to make sure that
we we're focused on the things that
create the
have the highest exposure to us and one
of the things that we focus on is
particularly when you think about the
likelihood and consequences of
actions or events
we particularly focus on what are the
consequences so think about anything
that could kill somebody or seriously
injure somebody is
something that we're very we're far more
interested and focused on that as
opposed to something which could occur
regularly but doesn't
doesn't have any great consequences so
we're particularly focused on looking at
the consequences and thinking about what
are the mitigation strategies and
uh charlotte provides us a regular
update on everything that has a serious
a very serious outcome even though the
likelihood of it is low and the
experience from some of other
organizations say they are the ones that
get the most into
difficulty or challenge you know it's
the that's the um
uh plane crash scenario you know they
don't occur very often but when they do
uh it goes badly wrong and making sure
that you do everything you possibly can
to minimize the risk of it of that
outcome is is where we focus so it is
about helping us prioritize but i
acknowledge that
um
we can we need to refine that if you're
looking for the graph that actually it's
not sitting in this report that actually
makes that up on page 41 of our agenda
is actually the the
matrix that we use that actually then
translates to the high medium and low
risk so if you want to see how those
risks are planning out it's that page
there that
explains our our current risk
matrix and and how things get to be high
medium or low in that
assessment
any further questions so we have
recommendation here somewhere here to
move
oh my counselor edmund will move it
seconded by
counts the mailings
council redmond
ah thank you mr mayor um i don't wish to
make any further comment except it's an
interesting exercise
and how this all works i'm suddenly
learning what a pro map is
something
i'd heard of but didn't really
understand
so anyhow i'm happy to move the report
second of counselor mailings
any further speakers
nothing to respond to so i'll put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that carried
thank you thank you charlotte
so next we have item 8.4
so mike is on his way in
we're now at 8.4 which is pages
126-135 that's on the
sustainability strategy implementation
mr o'connell
all right good afternoon um
okay the first report was done back in
march this is the second one that was
has been bumped to this meeting
it's an inr
risk committee report
um it read it's the second
summary of actions
in the implementation plan from the
sustainability strategy for the period
january to march of this year
um
and
really there's there's not a lot to say
about it other than that it's it's
an ongoing it's a qualitative measure of
how we're performing at the moment and i
think there are some concerns out there
that we possibly should be looking at
quantitative measures we haven't got
them specifically in the strategy at
this stage measuring and reporting
uh
but that will come
and
really i think that's all i can
at the stage others say that the report
has already been read and um
just a just a quick thing i don't
document we did we did uh spend five
thousand dollars less in fuel in the
second quarter whether that was january
holidays or some influence of the covert
i'm not sure yet but we'll have a look
i can bring those numbers back for
example in the third quarter report in
august to see where we're tracking on
fuel for example
so i'll leave it at that point
and take any questions
at a time with the recording system so
questions
councilor edmund followed by casa
stewart
thank you mr mayor on page 127 clause
4.4
uh could you update progress with those
discussions
we did have a submission on the annual
plan that said we weren't doing very
well in that space so i just wondered if
you could update us
sorry we weren't doing very well
okay um
look really that's not my area that's
vanessa um who's been looking at that uh
i just before lockdown we did have some
meetings about
that looking at potential suppliers and
there was
some issues around
whether we put out the tender whether
how we do the process but there were two
or three interested parties and
in the work we had doing because i think
they had got in contact with us because
they'd seen our our work in their area
was in the public realm and they'd seen
it and the field companies came to us
and i think we had two maybe three
so that was where i left it in march so
i really can't say anything more than
that
uh there's a briefing that we're um i
can't remember if it was next week or
the week after i think it's next week
that talks about eve it's an update on
evs uh for your consideration so
yeah i think there is still some
progress in that space
so we'll
cheer more next
week any further questions here counts
treatment
so counselor stuart
thank you i'm having issues with joining
this meeting
uh clearly um
a couple of things that i i raised last
time you bought and a um
a report to us which is just
a lack of progress on in-house recycling
and i notice
still here um there is not um
[Music]
a recycling system for the in-house
rubbish
and also we still have paper cups here
when they should go and we should be on
glass
what is the um what is the difficulty
here
oh sorry
um i can't say exactly we've got the
bins we've got about 10
12 sets of them sitting here and in
storage waiting to come out and i'm just
not sure what the what hold up isn't
rolling them out we'd like to have them
rolled out our sustainability sort of
action group
uh it pretty lies with property to to
make that
happen to bring them out
and other things on the on the paper
cups that's something we're working
through and we've got actions reinforced
actions for the second strategy coming
out the
stage 2 strategy to to look more closely
at disposable items and things like that
the question
they are really basic simple things
could we have an email round accounts
laws
um about what is the difficulty and when
are you going to roll out the in-house
recycling and just get rid of those
through the building
thank you
we did during the budget readings call
for a report more broadly
about the actions of the internal
working party just to see where those
measures were because there was a
submission that
referenced that
and there was some delays so we did
recall on it so perhaps more broadly
mike you could
just pick that up with elaine
and we would welcome perhaps a report
back or an email back in the interim
would be an answer to cancer stewart's
question but a broader report on where
those actions are at
similarly there is a
briefing session on the
23rd i think it's the 23rd of june mike
uh it's either the 9th or the 23rd my
memory is failing me about
sustainability update where we've got an
hour to talk about
trying to bring a number of
sustainability
issues
together for council
so if you wanted to you could leave it
till then um but picking up the comments
of colleagues
either a report or bring it up at the
time of the briefing if you've got time
councilor barnett's followed by council
duty
hello just a couple of questions the
first one is um what is the impact of
covert 19 emergency procedures had on
the sustainability strategy in-house
um it hasn't really allowed us to meet
face-to-face and
but saying that it's a
really it's been allowed me to progress
the second stage of the strategy um and
develop actions
for
excuse me
um for the upcoming strategy um the
revision process um
we are working through as much as we can
in the in the
the space that we have and that's what
our report is up until march so there's
not much more i can really add to that
sorry and the second question i just um
are you working with the portfolio
holder from the system who's got
sustainability on the council to get
some elected member support as well
uh yes i am and that's something that
we're still pushing along with and it's
actually a new action in the in the
upcoming strategy revision the new
revised action so that definitely is on
the agenda
thank you um
thanks for this report i just interested
in
this um
household solar energy
not
that you've had that presentation by a
particular company i'm just wondering uh
moving forward what is your
what is your thoughts on uh perhaps
promoting the solar household solar
energy
by the council how do you
what that and that was something you
could work with your um briefing so i'd
really like to know just how we can
perhaps
promote and and that forward
that's that's a good point um that
that's something that we've certainly
got as an action for the upcoming
strategy to look at producing
public um in fact i can just about
almost get the wording develop um
practical guidance for residents
to encourage sustainable building
practice that kind of thing so
definitely that's something that we've
got and trained to do
throughout through our building unit and
so on so to make make information
publicly available
council stuart
i'm having
difficulties again i'm offline
after being told i couldn't possibly i
am um
just again page one three one um
action
sc8 about turning off lights monitors
and appliance when not in use overnight
um
this is
can you tell me
why isn't that just
done is that done or you it's got
ongoing here i can't see why
uh that is a difficulty if staff
um told that they must turn off every
light before they exit the building in
all devices why is this
ongoing we've actually said that as a
well it's an action complete as and
we've we've tried to send out the
messaging but yes they're still ongoing
i i notice it when i leave the building
that there's still someone's left and
someone's left the light on for example
apparently there's an issue with through
it about whether
monitors or pc should be powered down or
just left it sleeping overnight it's
it's more energy efficient to leave them
powered down rather than actually
switched off and there's things like
updates and so on and virus checks so
it's a bit more complex than than
it looks
but we still try and do that through
through a messaging throughout through
the goal newsletter
etc
further questions
councilman that you prepared to move
seconded by councillor atkinson
yesterday
yes thank you for this report mike it's
very comprehensive it sees which shows
us where you were at as of end of march
and obviously the environment has now
changed a little bit some things we've
gone a step forward such as working from
home and in other steps we may have
taken a step back such as needing to use
disposable items rather than any sharing
of reusable items and so on reusable
coffee cups and so on can be a bit more
tricky
however i think this will evolve as we
go forward it's certainly something that
the public are demanding that we keep
trying to make progress in and that we
need to show leadership to the community
so i commend your group for putting your
hands up to do that and i do encourage
you work with the portfolio holder so
that you get the right traction at
governance level as well
so thank you for the report
second accounts reconciliation
things to me look this is something that
we will always grapple with there will
be always things that go wrong and
there'll be always things that go right
it's an ongoing as long as we're moving
forward and working with each other to
make it happen as is clearly evident in
the report by the results of it then i
think we are in the right space the
speed will always be a question and
i think that we just need to keep on
working with it and the questioning that
mike will get i'm sure takes on board
and uh it happens every time you sit in
front of us mike there's those questions
so i think that it's very pertinent that
we do that but we continue to improve
and and and get to a point where uh
where everybody's satisfied i have no
particular worries at the present time
with anything in this report but they
will always as i say be questions around
speed and
different people's expectations
further speakers
just throw my two cents in worth um look
mike does in actual fact liaise with me
quite regularly
this is a massive piece of work that
they've undertaken and it's it just gets
bigger and bigger really by the day
whenever you look at the
implications of how
sustainability does and should
rightfully should overarch everything
that we do
and um
this stage one that
we are
reporting on at the moment
is
really an in-house thing for us to get
our house in order and stage two we'll
we'll take
the strategy
a little bit further out into our
organization and and start to get into
the community
but i would just like to go back to um
page 57 in our agendas where um
simon very nicely put in a wee picture
from ariana huffington nothing should go
back to normal normal wasn't working
if we go back to the way things were we
will have lost the lesson maybe rise up
and do better and that goes for
sustainability infinity and beyond
so i would just really like to challenge
this council to
support the initiatives and um help us
all to keep pushing them through and and
make this happen because um we need to
take the lead
in our district with these changes and
um so far so good we just need to be a
little bit louder at trumpeting what
we're doing so thanks for your work mike
for the speakers write reply accounts
about it
so i'll put the recommendation all those
in favor eye
country to clear that carriage thanks
mike
right now we come to 8.5 um is paul
joining us or is he zooming
[Music]
paul christensen
yes
chief was chief was here
all right just uh just just i just need
to wait a minute just cleaning that
station
so you're not you're not operating sound
it is
so you're in zoom now or not
okay
thanks mike
so now we come to uh item 8.5 the
financial report for the period ending
31st of march
uh pages one three six two one seven
nine so we've got mr christian center mr
will milward mr christensen
thank you um this report is um to the
end of uh 31 march
um
so it was meant to be presented to the
order in respect because that's uh got
cancelled
so it's
a little bit
later reporting than we normally would
do um
the three main report points for this
report um the surplus was 3.4 million
against a budget of 10 million
the debt
at the end of march was 160 million
[Music]
against the budget of 185 million
and uh reverend revenue from the
development contributions was 4.5
million
which was under budget which was 9.3
[Music]
that
revenue cash flows from operations was
17.4 million
um
which is down against the previous same
time previous year
and
[Music]
cash flow cash flow
spent on investing was 27.9 million
[Music]
yeah is there any other questions on the
report
thank you mr christian so any questions
colleagues
no questions some are prepared to move
i'll move
seconded by
council brian
um
[Music]
really it just thought says it all there
in the report it's very it's good
reporting as always and i do appreciate
the effort that goes in here i think one
if we look at our the lgp report
recently and it does commend our council
and its financial performance and the
work that we're doing in this space so
it's a credit to to you mr christians
and mr millwood and all the team that's
in behind supporting so thank you for
your work in this space secondary
council brian
they're only industrial comments
any other any other
contributions any speakers
nothing to respond to so put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that carried
now we're in item 8.6 pages 180-217
the capital works report which is a
report in the name of
uh mr brown
mr cleary and also mr young so who's
taking the lead on the report today
mr young so
thank you
thank you uh mr mayor and councillors uh
yes presenting this report to you which
has been collated um
obviously during the
covered
process and reflects really our
state up until the end of march
i think it's fairly clear i won't go
through too much of the numbers there's
an awful lot of numbers in there but i
think it's fairly clear to uh to
everybody reading this that
um the numbers aren't
as we would like them to be
um they are lower than i think all of us
would
be comfortable with
we have sat in front of you with
on several occasions talking through
this report
and it's clear we're not making as much
progress in a timely manner to improve
the numbers
what i would like to suggest
is that there is an awful lot of work
going on in the background which are
improving the processes
uh that are
that we are working our way through
and in particular i think what you will
find in this coming year is that we have
begun the year
in a far more
ready state or we will be beginning the
year in a far more ready state
to advance
the various projects in this coming year
while we have been working on
reporting
the projects
through this last
12 months
and indeed acting on that information
as quickly as we can through that time
frame
it's always really difficult if you
haven't accept actually established the
project right from before the year even
starts
in a way which
is going to give a better chance of
success
we're in that process at the moment we
now have
procurement plans prepared
and in front of our
deliverers
uh on all projects
and those deliverers in particular uh
kelly lavallee the pdu manager is
working through preparing with her staff
detailed programs for each of the
projects coming up in the coming
financial year
this is going to be a really a key i
think in improving the performance of
the
delivery of the projects that along with
the other step that your staff and
managers have made which is to go
through
that program uh with a far more critical
eye than i think has happened before and
pushing out a lot of those
projects for further years so that we're
not
being overly optimistic in terms of what
we can achieve i think as you've
probably seen
there has been a little bit of a process
i think where we have allowed a bow wave
to build up as things have delayed
we have kept them
in our program without
possibly looking as as much
as closely as we should at the work that
is already there waiting for us
uh and whereas in this year
we certainly have taken a far more
rigorous uh approach to that um
other than that i'm not sure whether
chris and jarrod have anything they'd
like to add as a summary
so there's specific reference to a
number of the projects and under under
the i mean i don't think it's worth me
going through but we're happy to take
questions on any of them but if you look
through under the categories of
roading drainage we've actually tried to
pick out the key projects there and give
you a description of
what the issue was on them um look
you're going into the coming financial
year
from a three waters point of view we've
pushed out a huge amount so um and also
from a recreation point of view
other than the indoor courts um so the
indoor courts project's gonna be a big
one and that's look underway um that's
been
delayed uh by covert for as we would
have expected that to be further through
but the key one is going to be the
roading program and there is a real risk
around that as we talked about it the
annual plan deliberations it's very
ambitious
um
the so we're attacking that on a number
of fronts
we've got a far
bigger project and program management
role in the in the role um to date we're
don
reporting um that's going to be a much
more active role in the coming year
but the other uh thing is
when you look at the
within the report at the roading
projects in particular we
we've got a number of them that to get
them going we have to get some decisions
fairly early and we've already brought
one of those recently to the unr
committee for flaxton road there's
another report going to the rangiora
ashley community board for
southbrook so we're going to make sure
that we get those in front of elected
members early so that
key decisions can be made and we're
making sure we get the resource in
place so that's a that's a really big
focus for us in the coming year
when you stand back and look at the
total dollar spend the dollar spend that
we're proposing to spend in the coming
year approximately matches what we
actually
are spending in this current year
so um that does give
us more hope that we can actually
achieve it um previously we did have a a
larger
um
spend that was that was unrealistically
high so yeah look um chris don and i are
happy to take any questions
no that's fine thank you
questions
all right we got the recommendations so
moved by council reckons and seconded by
councillor becky council atkinson
thank you mr mean
um look i i move this and support what's
happening here
but i've heard these words before many
times
we will meet it we will do this we will
do that we don't
we need to
and if i sound a bit grumpy about that i
am because for two or three years we've
been told that
we've brought don on to to sort this out
so that we don't have the bear wave
we're hearing now and i get the reason
that we have the roading projects i
absolutely get why that is a bit of a
risky place to be
however we need to meet it
we need to outside those that are
uncontrollable we need to make sure that
we meet our program
and if that means cutting back our
ambition to do so we need to make sure
that we do that
so i certainly hope that we will get
to where we need to be in this in the
for the rest of the year and
sorry for the next year we have a
10-year plan coming up and my warning
shot across the bow is that i want for
the next 10 years a work program that
this council can meet generally there
will always be some anomalies but they
are far too big and need to come down
and we need to make sure of that while
the engineers are lovely at designing
programs and that's your forte that's
what you should do
we need to make sure that our ambition
matches our action
and we need for our right pass to make
sure that that happens
no thank you councillor atkinson's
covered that well
council stuart
yes thank you i wasn't going to say a
single thing because but
council atkinson has spurred me into
action which is to say exactly that
heard it before
don young is here to deliver
i'm surprised that i he's repeating what
he said a year ago i'm just saying i'm
tired of it too i you need to deliver
and all i can say is
exactly as soon as council atkinson said
a 10-year plan coming up
we need to deliver on what we're saying
we're going to deliver and if we cannot
and i'm really disappointed that in
taking all these projects out
and flopping them on
we still have
some uh
uncertainty about whether we're going to
deliver i understand that the roading um
the roading
program is ambitious
but look
if you if there is any
any
uncertainty about um
delivery let's just undercook it
and deliver it
and have that as a focus rather than
pushing this stuff out and now we have
got a bow wave we've got all the stuff
that you tell us we are going to deliver
in a capital works program this year has
rolled on to 2021-22
i don't think that's a goer um and i am
really going to be watching what you um
what you do with them this year because
mr young produced um i've got the
screens of it um at home a great big
capital works
program that was going to was going to
happen and it did not and part of it is
covered yes but in fact cobia really
only hit about um
february march
which is the tale well it's over halfway
through the program um for our um
for our year um what i'm saying is
i'm tired of hearing the same thing
so let's just pitch it where you can be
absolutely sure
of delivering it
thank you
followed by council duty casabana
look in a perfect world i would like to
see this at 800 too but we're not in a
perfect world and i think it's a little
unfair to actually put all the blame
back onto the staff when you look at
some of the reasons behind some of the
major capital
projects delays especially in roading
skewbridge is because nzta hasn't given
us the money
and so that money still stays just needs
to stay there because we are now trying
to pitch for it as a shovel-ready
project
so
we're in a catch-22 situation if we
suddenly got the money from nzt and
didn't have budget what would we do how
would we how would we justify that to
rate players um some of these projects
were actually pushed out because of the
amount of
consultation that needed to be done with
ratepayers which is actually a really
good reason to make sure it's done right
flaxton road is an example of that it
was the community board and utilities
and roading who sent that back for
further consultation points road was
delayed because we haven't been able to
have a public meeting so there's quite a
numerous if you actually look at the
reasons that there are some very good
reasons why a lot of these projects got
pushed out and some of them were really
major and if you have a few major
projects pushed out your percentages
look terrible so i can see a lot of
justification in here for what's been
done and our entire annual plan has now
been revised so therefore the capital
projects in the 2021 year will look
completely different um so i i am aware
of the concern and i i share it i'd like
to know what's happening in the next
year and i'd like to know that it's
realistic but i also understand the very
shifting sands that staff face in trying
to pin multi-year projects to one year
and also trying to add the
complexity of having to go through
multiple consultation phases and relying
on funding from exterior sources
so uh just just a little bit of caution
and and the amount of responsibility
that we've put on to staff because
elected members have some responsibility
in this too
thank you i'd just like to say to the
three members sitting there
congratulations well done you're working
very hard you've had a big task to do to
bring us back down after covert 19 and
to
to get where we need to have a
sensible rate increase so from my point
of view thank you
and i just like to share and the
comments are being expressed i think
council barnett put it really well i i
understand the reservations that
colleagues have in the way that this is
put and yes
i think the message is well understood
by our staff but i think there does need
to be a fair balance here
i remember talking to um i hear mr
wilwood saying in a forum we were in
that there perhaps is a better way of
expressing uh this those that we can
actually achieve
and those that we may achieve because
we've always got an ambitious program
because that's how we achieve funding
and then we look at the statistics later
and they may not match perhaps the
expectation and that's been the
challenge since i have been on council
uh and it's been a long
it's been over a long number of years no
one's actually managed to crack it i
thought what mr millwood suggested
recently had some merit so maybe it's
worth
exploring that with jeff a little
further
um in the covert situation as has been
mentioned a lot has changed and and yes
we may be looking at
hearing in a few
certainly a bit later on in reporting
that we're not matching the expectations
we'd like to from the statistic
statistical perspective here but i think
we need to move a bit beyond that i know
our staff are taking it on board
i think there's a better way of
expressing this that may help um us in
terms of justifying those numbers but i
would just like to
acknowledge the work that is going on in
that space it's a huge it's a huge work
program here thank you for what you do
but i also understand that
um sentiments express that we need to
look at how we're expressing that
because when it comes back and we're not
achieving
you know there is regular concern i
don't know how you fix that entirely
unless you have a uh as we all want an
ambitious work program but it's how you
maybe express that that may be worth
considering council award
thank you mr mayor i just want to say um
i do acknowledge that you have a
humongous workload and you do really
really well and if as councillors we can
help you by making decisions in a more
timely fashion so that you can actually
get on with your job and not duplicate
things well then that would be great
just all i can say is god's been
any further speakers councilmatics
being a new kid on the block i can't say
that i have heard this before so this is
the first time i've i'm hearing it but
whenever i read this report
i thought to myself okay well gosh you
know we've just asked you guys to
rationalize heavily
that the program of works that you were
doing due to coping 19 and what we've
we've asked you to do
to minimize the rate's impact so i
understand that
and also due to covet 19 three of the
best construction months of the year
have also been taken away from us
so we we've lost march april may
so i also get that and also some of the
things were due to consultation as
my colleagues have um previously brought
to mind
i understand that too whenever you take
three months out of the schedule as well
we've got 69 percent here
um
you know three months is
25 percent of the year's worth of um
construction i get that that makes sense
um
you are tasked with an impossible
herculean task
so far so good i i do hope that you know
this is an anomaly and i know that you
guys have
well and truly got the capabilities to
do what needs to be done so we can get
done what needs to be done so i
at this point looking at this and and
the obstacles that you have
overcome i take my hat off to you so
well done and hopefully we will have a
higher batting average next year
thanks
interesting observation mr mia um after
ross mathis died and councillor kane
joined us this was her
catchphrase and quite frankly i'm not
too worried
about the carryovers
never have been neither will we they're
inevitable
and
our staff do the best they possibly can
to manage them
that's what i've got to say
further speakers
council reconsider raj reply
thank you mr mayor um
i've heard the speeches
of uh support there's not one person i
don't believe in this room or just about
anywhere that actually sits and doesn't
support our staff for what they do
what i'm saying is as their advisors is
that we need to know truthfully what we
can achieve and what we can't achieve
now that's what we need to know
sometimes it's tough for us we say we
want this and we want that the answer is
sorry i can't deliver it
very rarely do we get told that it comes
back as oh yeah i think we can fit that
in we need to change this from that but
we can actually achieve it asked many
times i've asked it many times myself so
as other councillors can we get there
yes we can we get to the end of the year
and it hasn't happened
and there may be some reasons around
that we talk about extra consultations
we talk about um
the the funding from outside agencies
our job is to manage that
our job is to make sure that we get that
in line and say instead of 2022 because
we are going to have to do these things
it'll be 2023
instead of going through and carrying
over all the time
council brian's absolutely right i've
been sitting around this table myself
for 19 years i've listened to it every
year
we need to get better at it
and that's what i'm saying let's get
better let's do better at it we will
never get 100
unless we have a program that we can get
somewhere near achieving so if it's a
100 million dollar program
let's budget for 95 million and come
back for five million dollar deficit
funding if we have to to achieve and
then all of a sudden you've achieved
shall we say 110 to the program not
let's get realistic about what it is we
can and can't do
i've seen the screws of paper that the
councillor stewart is talking about and
and mr young put them in front of us and
i thought these are great this looks
like we're actually heading somewhere we
actually know where we're going we had
the colors we had everything in front of
us but here we sit here again in the
same situation and we can use covert as
an excuse if we want to and but i mean
if you take 25 of a budget because it's
25 percent of the year and you move that
out you look at the same thing we've
still got huge carryovers we need to fix
it
thank you um so we come to
the recommendation
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye
contrary
declare that carried
thanks don gerald and chris well
i think it's appropriate time now we
might break for
afternoon tea um so if we could be back
here about
ten to four please
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
thank you so we now move to um do you
want to deal with 6.1 first or do you
want to do with 8.7 jared
sorry
i'm happy to talk to 6.1 and then 8.7 in
that order
since that was it
um 6.1 which was the adjoined business
pages 26 to 37 the
review of the terms of reference for the
land and water committee it's a paper in
the name of sophie but we've had some
technology issues so jared's going to
talk us through that mr cleary thank you
thank you so this report is uh coming to
you it should be no no surprise this is
something that has been talked about for
some time
it's really um
it's actually just a much more efficient
way of doing things over time we
established the kaipoi river river
rehabilitation working party and we
established the cam river
enhancement subcommittee
and then more recently the council has
established the land and water committee
and at the time that it was established
there was always an undertaking that
staff would bring this report back
it's more efficient for staff to be able
to service one
group
more efficient for the elected members
to turn up to one meeting and deal with
all of the matters that are all related
and also it involves a lot of
other parties such as doc environment
canterbury
local ewe and so it's from their point
of view it's better for them to have one
point to come in um there was a question
around
the chem river
fund so there are some specific
requirements
in the environment court decision
we can still fulfill those obligations
um
through this structure we
we actually established the cam river
working party in a way to
keep all those parties involved on board
but what we need to do is whenever we
are
carrying out any works or spending the
money we need to do that in agreement
with fish and game
and in consultation with the department
of conservation so the other words out
of the encore environment court decision
um we can uh still fulfill that in this
structure so happy to take any questions
thank you questions council blackie
partially answered my question um
with doc and ecan and such like i think
it says in there somewhere it's the
responsibility of the committee members
to
beat them information but it's going to
be okay
either having them or not having them at
on
assorted land and water committee
meetings
uh yes
yes absolutely fine not having them
there
when we are making decisions around the
cam river fund
then we need to make sure that we have
agreement with fish and game so that
doesn't necessarily happen at the
meeting um and we do need to consult
with the department of conservation so
we whether they're at the meeting or we
do that through another mechanism is
fine
no well the kaipo river rehabilitation
working party doesn't have um
those
requirements imposed by the environment
court that was a the reason we
established the kaiapoi river working
party was because originally there was a
gap nobody was actually taking real
responsibility for the river so it was a
way to get environment canterbury the
council and other parties around the
table we can still do that through this
forum
questions
we've got a recommendation that some are
prepared to move moved by council stuart
seconded by council williams council
stuart
thank you mr may i really happy to move
this this is a really common sense um
development of bringing all our river
environmental type um
particular projects um into
this committee um just to allay uh our
councillors
concerns
the um
the cam river fund has in essence been
totally allocated pretty much
and fish and game was on the
enhancement fund committee at that point
and
department of conservation actually gave
their tick off to the program not all of
it of course in fact very little little
of it being delivered because we were
waiting and still waiting i think on the
consent from ecan to do these more
substantial works
and
um as chair of land and water i'd be
keen that once we did get going again
with the ability to
deliver on these projects that we do
actually
um
at least
as a matter of courtesy go back to fish
and game and docks
telling them we're underway but the the
program the money as i said has been
allocated to particular projects
we just haven't been able to um deliver
on them because of consent issues
so it makes a lot of sense as i said
earlier to bring it all under um
one committee and really keen to see um
delivery of these programs in the next
um
wee while thank you
for the speakers
there's nothing to respond to so i'll
put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear it carried thank you
we now come to
item
8.7 seafoam sampling update pages
218-224 miss kiri
thank you this
report is
summarizing the testing that was carried
out last summer so
we did manage to get some sea foam
samples collected
and tested
so
you can see the locations uh on that on
the diagram on page 220 which is the abc
and d points um and then the results are
summarized um in section
four it's really it's important to note
there's actually no standards for what
um levels of e coli or intracocci you
get in c foam and
uh this is pretty um experimental i
suppose um
the work that we're doing
um the other important point is
at the time we took the sea foam samples
we also took water samples and
and on all occasions those water samples
were below the limits in the in the sea
water
now the reasons you get really high
numbers
in
the
seafoam when you compare it to water
uh
the um bubble scavenging and replication
that occur so basically the bubble the
the bubbles themselves actually just
accumulate um bacteria and then they
actually provide they like a little
greenhouse so when the foam sitting on
the beach
um you get the nutrients you've got nice
warmth
and so they can
you know bacteria under ideal conditions
to can replicate every 20 minutes um and
double their number each time and and so
that growth is very exponential so
you'll see um you can you know if you
look at some of those samples those
numbers might look quite high but that's
not um an unexpected result to get that
in
this kind of environment um sophie has
had discussions with cph and environment
canterbury about these results
and they are not recommending any action
as a result of these
um
and particularly given that the water
samples are still in compliance
um look we'll uh continue we can
continue to do this um the the
uh
most of the cost is collection
so
we're and we're managing that without
without our own staff resources and
getting those to the lab um so that we
can continue to uh monitor it over the
over the coming summer but just given
we're into winter now we've put that on
hold so look
i'm look happy to take any questions on
this
um
dude just just given the um
the numbers that are here and and i mean
really hard when you don't know
quite what level that number is at sort
of thing um in the fact that they're so
high to what they they should be on the
e-coli
this stuff lies on the beach
what danger you're saying that it get as
it as it heats
it gets exponentially worse so therefore
the
e coli gets worse every time what does
that do to people who are walking
through it to people that are
animals that are walking through it and
so on i mean whether it's lying on the
beach or i mean obviously it's not in
the water get there
but this foam is lying on the beach
with these high levels of e coli in them
what what danger does that pose
well these i suppose there's a couple of
points
this this is not the only location in
the world where seafoam occurs so it's a
naturally occurring phenomena um all
around everywhere
um
the certainly there's no uh cph it's
because specif sophie has had this
specific conversation they've got no
record of people getting sick from sea
foam
um
whether that means no one ever has or
they don't or or
when people do get sick from swimming
whether it's just from purely the water
or foam i don't know their answers to
all of those and they're really
interesting questions and they're
extremely hard to would be extremely
hard for us to actually answer
that um
it's
and but but look there's certainly no
evidence that these are heightened risk
because of that to the public in um
this area that you wouldn't necessarily
get anywhere else you might see sea foam
and
i'm i'm having
trouble understanding how there's no
heightened risk if you've got
huge numbers of like e coli as i said i
don't know whether that's at a danger
zone or not a danger zone and what we've
got how can that not be a heightened
risk if it's up there and the fact that
no one's had it means what does that
actually mean for us i mean does it mean
what does it mean i mean
i mean you're right there's seafoam
everywhere i mean i go to the
sunshine coast and i'm in the fc phone
that's a foot deep
um you know two feet deep um but it's
certainly nowhere near an ocean outfall
and doesn't have
e coli in it so
i'm
these facts are here about the
heightened level so
how do we find out whether that actually
means something or not
well
the
the presence of e coli or intracocci
isn't there indicator organisms so they
show that there is life there um
it's there is
from warm blooded animals um
and it has got the ability to to
replicate on its own so once you get you
those naturally occurring bacteria in
the environment um
i suppose because we don't have uh any
advice from the cph to say that they're
concerned about the health risk we
really are relying on their expertise in
terms of what that public health risk is
you know to really answer it this would
be you know phd research material for
people who are working in
public health and
in the environment environment
and certainly well beyond our ability to
be able to do that you know we're
limited in terms of actually being able
to go out and record it um and then talk
to the experts about it
mr richmond
thank you mr mayor um
jared have we tested the discharge
before it's discharged
um
of the ocean outfall
material
before it enters the sea do we know
the e coli levels in in there
yes yes so we've got regular sampling we
do
uh on the discharge
prior to
being disposed of
and we sit within our consent limits on
all of the parameters so we've got
specific um
requirements that we need to achieve we
report that publicly including to the
council
i'm happy to find the most recent report
and i can
send that to you councillor edmund which
gives you a good summary of that
supplementary question
are we any closer to knowing the source
of the e coli
contamination now
no
and we're saying that's too hard
we've actually tried to do fecal source
tracking which is quite expensive
and
we did spend quite a lot of money on
that
and we we just can't get enough in the
sample to be able to do that you need to
have large volumes of water with a
higher level of
e coli or intracroco in it and we just
don't we haven't got the ability to
gather samples in those concentrations
and needed to give you that result so
we we are not able to advise what that
source is just because it's not able to
be tested
yeah
are we going to or do you think it's
necessary for us to send we letter to um
michael bate
regards their
findings here that um we've sent the
results to the other agencies and
i've come back
with a mutual set of
certification certification and result
well satisfactory results um
on the yeah it is too much coke
you know on the results is it worth
doing
yes he'd be happy to do that we did send
off um a letter relatively recently to
um michael bate
but look we can specifically give him
one that that
references this report and we'll include
a copy of the
the report and also um hone in on that
particular point
any further questions
so we have a recommendation here some
are prepared to move
moved by council awards seconded by
council stuart councillor what do you
speak
yes thank you um i'd thank you i just
want to say that um i just really feel
that this is not really
nothing to worry about i've seen lots of
seafoam um on the west coast uh which is
much much greater this usually happens
with um
in
a storm situation
and i've seen it happen in sydney i've
seen it happen everywhere
i'm quite happy about the e coli i think
if you probably tested some of the
ground around where it sits you'll
probably get the same
result so um
uh
and i'm happy with this report and i
don't think we need to take it too much
further and i'm happy that you're doing
it within the the same working people
that you've got thank you
mr stewart
thank you
um this has been a long running saga to
come to this conclusion and i do welcome
this conclusion it has cost the council
quite a lot of money
and i um
i'm not um
criticizing that at all um though it has
got to a point now where we're actually
pioneering science here and whether um
there has been an assumption from
members of the public that the
the e coli or enterococco in the seafoam
sample comes from our a malfunctioning
[Music]
sewage treatment plant that's actually
not the case we meet our consent on
every level
so i think that message needs to clearly
go out there it could be
that um
we've got a um a poopy beach from the
fact that there are sea birds um
letting their um internals go um uh and
being washed in uh to the to the shore
um people's dogs the whole deal
um and as jared has said are very
difficult and very expensive um
to um do some physical source tracking
in fact we
as he said attempted it
massive volumes needed to
have anything that would be
scientifically um
significant and we're just unable to do
that sort of um
study
so i think i'd agree uh we've we've done
our best to um
to determine whether there is a public
health risk um and i am quite
comfortable
with the fact that um our public health
uh organized authorities are comfortable
with where we're at here
um
sophie was able to look through the the
data
internationally and and find that
there'd only been one or two studies in
japan where seafoam had
been
studied so we are actually pioneering
work here and i think
uh it is time to put uh this
investigation to rest
though i agree with jared if um
if people if staff are out there
sampling um for our consent and there is
a whole
whack of sea foam then certainly um
have another go at it but
um as he's described
the foam acts as a
uh grill with where we're at in the
recommendation
thank you
thanks councillor stuart councillor
atkinson
thank you mr mia
look
i'm not gonna not support this but i'm
not comfortable with we're at no one
seems to know anything about everything
that we've got
and um
the most sensible suggestion or
maybe not a suggestion but a phd student
may be able to actually take this on and
do a thesis and find out what it's like
we're not talking about normal sea foam
here look i've traveled around australia
i've traveled around new zealand to sea
foam on every beach we're talking about
scum that is in the sea foam on our
beach we don't know whether it's coming
from christchurch we don't know what
it's from we don't know where it is we
haven't done that we just don't know
so what we don't know we don't know but
it'll be kind of nice to find out and if
that's
i mean we've done what we can do i i get
that as a as budgets allow us to do that
but we really need to know what what
this is all about i mean it's not on
every beach
i've seen sea foam right around the
country and it doesn't look like the sea
foam that's on our beach it's not brown
and horrible and gross stuff as the day
goes on and leaves scum lines right
across
the um
the beach line at the the tide marks i
mean you guys have all seen the photos
that have come here on it i mean it it
doesn't happen in other places the sea
phone comes and it goes comes and it
goes
disappears all together but the actual
scum lines in this and and the brown
horrible stuff that's in it it lies to
me in my head with some real questions
and especially when you're talking about
exponentially growing e coli in it
in in the sun and the temperature and
you know all of those sorts of things so
i would like to know more i think as a
council we've done what we can do it
took us far too long to do it in my view
but we've done it
i i actually think that i'd like to see
someone like a phd student
to do a phd thesis on what it is if we
could encourage someone to do it and
that might be
something this council could do in the
future to actually help and find out
some of those things right around the
world because surely someone must need
to know what it is that's sitting in
some of these beaches i mean we just
seem to
glaze over the top the sea foam it's
this is different it while it is
sea foam it's what's in that sea foam
you don't see it in other places around
the world oh sorry around the world i'm
not that world um
around australia in our country it's not
there it's just normal seafoam that
comes and goes with the tide but that's
not what we have on our beach
thank you i'd like to endorse councillor
atkinson's comments
i'm just turning to recommendation c
on page 219
my main concern is that we have
guidelines
for e coli in seawater
but we don't have them in seafoam and as
we've discovered the levels in seafoam
can be
much higher
and it's way bit of a cop-out i think to
say that um
the recreational water quality
guidelines
do not apply to sea foam therefore there
is no exceedance of the trigger level
and no action is required
so
it's not for us to set those guidelines
but i would like to think that we may
approach environment canterbury
and public health um with a view to
establishing guidelines
um
because
just to say well there are no guidelines
so there's no problem that that to me
doesn't solve the issue there does
appear to be an issue and we're sort of
pussy-footing around trying to find the
the source of it
and i must admit i'm nonetheless
to be fair but um i would like to
encourage the council
to see if environment canterbury and
public health would consider guidelines
for
uh seafoam
um it may even be that they are the same
as the uh
water quality guidelines i don't know
i'm not a scientist
but otherwise i'm supportive of the
recommendations
because the brain
when i was nine months old at the ashley
uh river mouth
and i made these comments when this
issue was first
raised and we've since spent an awful
lot of money
um
this has occurred for years
for years and years it's and it's on
again off again
you know you might see it perhaps two
three times a year you might see it once
during the white black season and it
clogs up on your screens
and you've got to wash it off when you
get back to the batch it's been
happening for years and years and years
well you know i'd love a student to do a
thesis on how it occurs but i'm quite
sure it's naturally occurring
and that would answer any questions but
i'm very opposed
uh to any suggestion that uh we spend
any more money on it
let alone ask environment canterbury
to spend any money on it
thank you for the speakers counsellor
sorry yes
houston
and i i think when we consider this
report we've always got to consider two
questions
and the first question is is the ocean
out full
having some cause for this seafoam
there's been no scientific evidence
shown to prove prove that at all and in
fact the contrary's been proven our
sampling has shown that everything is
within consent limits
so
at that point
it becomes really hard because the
scientific evidence is telling us this
is not the case the second question is
is the safe home harmful
and whose responsibility is that
and at that point the responsibility
falls back to the dhb
because that they look after human
health
now if they have not indicated to us as
a council that they expect us to take
some action us or he can
take some action to help
with human health risk
then we cannot consider that and we
should not be spending money on that
we are spending rate payers money
on an area that's not our responsibility
we have seen
cyanobacteria in our lakes we have seen
other algal blooms i've seen algal
blooms up and down the country that
cause problems and it's often an organic
source
much as you see organic sources on farms
organic sources in the dog park or
organic sources all around the place
we live in a natural world and that
means that we live surrounded by
different types of growth which are not
particularly helpful to humans
in this particular case i come back to
the responsibility question is our ocean
outfall at fault the evidence says no
is the sea farm harmful that's not up
for us to debate today that's up for the
dhb to take some measures if it's been
proven to be harmful
further speakers
write of reply council award
i'm fine thanks
all right so we have the recommendation
before us all those in favor please say
aye
contrary to clear they're carried
thank you so we now move thank you mr mr
cleary are you joining mr stevenson for
this next report you are yep
thank you
so now at uh item 8.8 new zealand
vertical datum
2016 adoption mr stevenson
uh to report in the name of mr stevenson
mr simpson
pages 225 to 299.
so um are you taking the lead on this mr
stevenson
so it's just one speaker at a time with
us so once you finish click off
accordingly so vanessa's listening in
the background she can hear that too
all good
thanks mia gordon um
thank you councillors
can you hear me now
i'm not usually a quiet speaker
this report seeks your approval
for uh the adoption of the new zealand
vertical datum 2016. so hopefully their
reading wasn't too too dry
council currently uses littleton
vertical datum 1937. okay we've used
this for many years it's uh taken from
the tide gauge in littleton and how the
marks and survey marks throughout the
district are
leveled as is from that mark throughout
by um by leveling it's a very expensive
uh way of keeping marks up to date
nowadays we've got gps and the like and
uh that's where a lot of the nzbd stuff
is coming into fruition
lenses
approached all councils across the
country and has asked that they looked
to adopt new zealand vertical data in
2016. it is the
current
standard for
vertical datums within the country and
there's a lot of benefits in adopting it
we've also been approached by
other firms to look at adopting it
and i've seen plans come in even for our
own stadium here that has been in nzvd
2016.
so it is being
utilized by a lot of firms across the
country already although you know we
expect to see it in our littleton
vertical datum 1937
normally
an adoption
of nzvd
would see us updating the district plan
and also the engineering code of
practice
utilizing it as as perth as perth 4.3 of
this report
and would then also
bring it to the attention of all
external consultants that either work
for or work for developers and others
throughout the district and in
christchurch city as well
um
we're not alone uh selwyn and
christchurch city council have committed
to adopt nzvd uh
so and uh soon with christchurch city
they haven't exactly said when they'll
adopt it but they have said that they
will adopt it so that's that's good news
and across the country there's been many
that already have adopted
nzvd
essentially staff think it's a good way
forward and
give us some certainty on on datums
from now on into the future and will
align with
lenses
mandated in a way but also any data that
we're getting from them in terms of
lidar and things like that as well so i
think it's it's a good way forward
so yeah look um open the questions
thank you mr stevenson any questions
council stuart
thank you
if in fact um it is intimately sort of
adopted throughout the country um which
you're indicating
everyone presumably will work towards
adopting it
or is it up to individual councils to
say yay or nay what does it mean um for
um
plans that may be done from a consultant
in a in an area where
they're on a different datum than than
is here
i mean yeah
oh sorry
so i think there's a there's i think
it's 13 different regional datums across
the country
and
if you're doing work in
in that part of the country then you're
doing it to that datum so if you're
working in the waimakariri or even
partially over the west coast in
christchurch in south canterbury you're
working to the littleton vertical datum
so that would be consistent
uh
if
basically from first july there will be
some work in progress where they'll be
using
the littleton vertical data we'd still
accept that because we can still
transform that data
but then say this time next year someone
presents us with something like that
would say hey look you need to give it
to us in nzvd please yeah because
otherwise we're having to do some work
to make it right
but yeah it is regionally specific
by going across the country these 13
vertical datums will be uh abolished
over time and that's that's what wins
wants to see
which is
quite a good thing
so i've got a meeting with an architect
on thursday evening for a build that i'm
going to do out of waikoku next year
do people know that there's if we adopt
that that's changing and what they need
to do
certainly that'll be my task to make
sure they do know and get that as
disseminated as far and widely as
possible
uh there'll be firms in town and town
architecture firms that
uh look i probably won't pick up all of
them but i will pick up the major
consultants that do work out here in
architects that do work out here because
we'll also let our building department
they'll
go to their contacts and known
consultants to make sure that they're
advised as well so yeah it's quite an
it is a big
big job but it is just a contact list
and an email that goes out with some
information fact sheets so
the questions
counselor um violence followed by
council redmond
just questioning whether you've talked
to the district plan team and whether
there's any impacts for our district
plan review going forward
yeah certainly aware and
i guess
it's quite weird but in our district
plan we have different terms as well
like amsl average mean sea level i don't
quite know what that means but i have to
relate that back to littleton 1937
so just tidying up all of that stuff as
well to get it into a consistent format
going forward that's the that's the key
so yeah once this goes out it'll be yeah
it'll be consistent
supplementary to that just wondering
about the
pre-notification post notification
impacts is there likely to be many
impacts on
development
in the in the district with the changing
of levels
so there are developments underway that
are working to a a datum that they've
had since the start okay
i can give some examples like
west park or windsor park where
uh we'd adopted
littleton vertical datum 1937 but we put
the january 2018
they actually updated all of their as
built
to the new datum but there are others
that
have been so long and in progress
that they just haven't and we just need
to be sure
of the date stamp on that time because
we can we can work
from an older data and convert it to a
new one but we've got to have that data
as to when it happened so
yeah and that that's that's the same
with
any capital works or renewals drawings
that we've got as long as we've got that
date stamp we know when that was
the moment in time that that was set
custer edmund
thank you the littleton
datum appears to be about 83 years old
and a lot of things relate and it is
coming to a question with me
[Laughter]
a lot of historical things relate to um
calibration and little littleton
littleton time ball um was designed to
help ships calibrate their navigational
equipment um
and i mean things move on over time are
there any downsides to adopting this new
standard
sorry
the only downsides that i can see is
that there's a little bit of work to get
conversion of all of our existing data
but
that can be quite easily done
i i look
yeah i can't think of any but i look to
the positives and i look at all the
marks that we've got on nzvd throughout
the
district there's over 400 versus like
180 for lvd so it's going to make it
easier for builders and
surveyors to
to
survey finish floor levels or surfaces
or new
assets and infrastructure i think
there's going to be more marks that they
can choose from in order to
say close the loop
when they're doing the works
but yet there is certainly a lot of
history
to uh lvd in fact i got called up last
year by elliott
and a senior server from elliot sinclair
and he's been he's been mapping it for
his career
and uh but he was a proponent of us
going to nzbd
as well he says look
uh lvd just is it's not even true now to
what it was you know it
goes up and down you know obviously with
title patterns and things and mapping he
said look we'd better go to the to the
geoid or the
you know the satellite
system so
yeah so
in terms of negatives
some money up front now but it's going
to save us a lot of money anyway going
forward and
yeah i can't see any other negatives
okay
council williams has indicated he's
prepared to move seconded by
council brian
kessler williams
you know i think it's a modern way of
moving forward and um it's the long term
we're going to be savings on it it's
probably sounds to me like it's going to
be a bit more accurate so um
good move thank you
any further speakers council redmond
uh just one item mr mayor i take it this
report was originally
prepared for the unr committee
so we may like to change reference
to that committee to the council
recommendations
yeah yeah it wasn't in the report that
i'm looking at thank you
um sorry write a reply counsel williams
but then i'll put that all those in
favor please say aye contrary to clear
carriage
thank you mr stevenson mr cleary
[Music]
adrian
i'm not worried
i can't even get into it at all
so it might even let me in
that's all right
what else is going on that's the windy
year just sitting there that's all right
who cares
oh
all right order everyone
thank you
um
we come back we come now to item 8.9
which is the implementation plan for the
town
entrance standard strategy we have with
us vanessa thompson and don young denise
are you taking the lead on this
don so pages 300-329
mr young
thank you miss mia and councillors um i
got involved in this project
when when we were working our way
through the various roading projects
that needed
to be thought about and advanced for
this coming year
and
it became clear that this project in
particular has
far more complexities than it first
would meet the eye it's
really does have an awful lot of
stakeholders in different groups who are
interested and involved in in sorting
through
uh solutions here so i organized a
meeting with the various internal groups
of which there are three departments
involved there
including vanessa who had been doing
quite a bit of work in this space
previously and what became apparent at
that very first meeting
is that with issues like this um there
is the risk and in particular have been
highlighted that with this one there was
the risk
that
staff could progress
issues like this quite
a long way
and that that
potentially led to
quite a bit of confusion when we got to
the end of it
in terms of the council's actual
willingness to fund what the community
were discussing and agreeing to
and so there is an awful lot of work
with these there are 20 different sites
for just for
town
towns which you would describe as an
entrance
uh and of those
there are a number of different groups
in in each of them
so you could pick any one of those town
entrances and and it would be a
reasonable project in itself
to advance through to a point where you
had a design and a costing
and were prepared to come to the council
and say this is what we want to build
here
and
the punch line a little bit was that we
felt it would be better to get it is a
little bit chicken in the egg
you
as the council may well say well we're
not prepared to say what we want to fund
until you've come back to us with some
ideas
but on the counter to that if you give
us an idea
of your of of the intention of funding
then it assists with those conversations
with our community and ensures the
expectations are
matched right from the start
now
we as staff have
i won't quite say picked a number out of
the year but it is a little bit of a
random number of fifty thousand dollars
a year
which is intended to be
effectively a top up
for three or four sites that there is
already works happening at
um to do a little bit more than
otherwise would happen if there was no
specific budget to ensure that a town
entrance
type outcome
was achieved
so this
particular
paper
asks that you give an indication to the
community for when we begin our
conversations knowing of course that
that community in turn will have a hold
of view on that and may well feel
inclined to come back to you at the time
that the ltp
is then pulled together
and expressed to you whether they see
this as an appropriate level of funding
but it starts the ball rolling in terms
of that two-way conversation between the
council and wearing his funding hat and
the community and i'd put the community
boards in that camp and the community in
terms of what they would like to see
and when they would expect to have it
built we then also moved on to the
settlements
and again there's another
reasonable task to identify
the the treatment at the outskirts of
the settlements
the work that vanessa has done has moved
us a long way towards that in that we
have firstly identified what are the
settlements and then generally had
conversations about the level
that you could expect the entrance of a
settlement which is
relatively low level it's it's it's
really not much more than uh some
bulbous curbs and planting and a bit of
signage
so those expectations have already been
discussed and accepted but this report
does go one step further by suggesting
that until we get a clearer idea
of
what we are doing and what the council
does wish to spend then let's
concentrate on the town entrances
and put the lid on the settlement
entrances apart from those instances
where again work may emerge that meant
look we're on site anyway let's just
finish this off
so that gives a little bit of an
explanation about why this report is
here and why it is here very early in
the process which has still got a long
way to go in terms of deciding what are
we going to do at each of our town
entrances
not sure if there's anything more you
wanted
is that the settlements phase two we're
hoping to bring back to the audit and
risk committee in the next couple of
months for adoption so that's not too
far away at the moment it's just being
reviewed by staff
um and then i'll just edit it and then
hopefully flick it through to
the ana committee soon
that's all
thank you questions councilor atkinson
followed by council stuart
thank you mr mayor i thought you might
have a fun bit of fun putting this
together
it's never an easy one this one um
a couple of questions actually first one
is settlements it's my understanding
that nzta put road signs up for
settlements and they are already there
why would we
go further than that so that's that's
that question
and then
around number two is more around funding
i mean i don't actually have a problem
too much with what's in front of us is
repeating but the
the second one comes to input from towns
and and
what
sort of spurred my interest in this was
that the photo you had in the venessa of
um
of the kai point entrance sign which in
fact is not the type of entrance sign it
belongs to the rotary
so around um
around funding
are we in this investigation as we go
further going to go to the rotaries the
the lions the um
the community boards with their uh
discretionary funding all of those
people to bolster that funding and put
in entrance signs is that the sort of
discussion that's going to go on is that
where we need to be i mean you could
council could put a 50 000 you could
come up 50 000 worth of public money um
for certain towns so just is that where
we're heading with us
um i guess it's something we can
certainly consider and that will
probably come out in part of the
community consultation phase so looking
at kai poi as an example if the
community indicated that particular sign
in the south
entrance on main north road that they
wanted to bolster or do a bit more
around and then we'll probably approach
rotary and see if there's some
additional funding we can add to the
pool i guess we just have to take that
on a case-by-case scenario and look at
what signs we're treating and what other
opportunities are available around those
yes
yes yes the settlements in terms of
signs i guess once again we need to look
at that
i know we just did one recently i think
for waikoku beach where the community
helped design that
sign so there may still be a desire from
the community's point of view to
actually design their own signs for
their settlements because as you know
the nzta ones are quite um beer
so i guess that once again would come
out as part of that consultation if
there was a desire we would travel down
that path if not we would maybe look at
that putting additional money into more
landscaping or some other treatment
oh okay
it's just clarification really so the
existing signage that is throughout the
district
that is um
uh to be worked on and gone back to the
community to see if they're satisfied
with that yeah because i mean you've got
as as councillor atkinson said that's
the rotary sign the actual kai voice
sign which was 45 green
is the one near the kaikanui with the
flowers growing on over it that you
can't actually read when you're coming
into
kaiapoi
but i i'm
yes
yes which was and vanessa nodded is this
basically stay
what's already there you go back to your
community and say do you want more than
this or are you quite happy with what
we've got
i guess we can adjust what's there or we
can just put new new signs in so i think
what we did is identify entrances where
they could do with some enhancements or
beautification some of those may have
signs or stuff in place infrastructure
already that we can potentially enhance
or replace items some of those entrance
areas have nothing so it's a case of do
we want to put additional signs there is
that something the community wants to
support and that's what we would explore
through that community consultation
process essentially
does that answer the question
yeah i'm just concerned with uh we're
making a rod for our back we're doing
this because
um low moon's not meant since report
pegasus has not mentioned this report
fern side just want to know are they all
going to come on the bandwagon when they
read this
wanting money for their um
settlements as well um i'd imagine
um the lobin people
yeah after this question it's the low
burn people will think this is a nice
settlement that's probably um
well advanced so
as i mentioned earlier we're gonna bring
back the phase two settlements in a
couple of months and you'll see some of
those small settlements will be listed
in that document in terms of how we
treat them so we we originally picked
the towns for the phase one towns we
chose them because they were listed in
the dds district development strategy so
we've taken a similar approach with the
settlements and picked the settlements
out of the dds that were listed in that
but of course that's open for discussion
so once that document comes forward if
there's additional settlements that we
haven't mentioned that you feel or the
community boards feel need to be
included we will of course consider that
as staff pegasus is actually mentioned
in phase one towns but we decided not to
treat um we had looked at the main
entrance and as well as bob robertson
drive and decided um the main entrance
didn't actually need additional
enhancements because it was looking
lovely with the signs and stuff bob
robertson drive at the time we were
going to probably come back and review
it once um rayburs ravens would have
developed a bit more and then we're
going to consider that again but
yeah so we'll come back to you on those
settlements and you'll see them in phase
two
yes thank you i i guess my perception is
to use your terminology council against
the rod for your back is actually the
strategy
in terms of we are consulting with the
community about what they would like and
that process has already begun it is
underway so the intention of this is to
put a pocket bucket around or a box
around that rod to say
whatever you guys come up with out there
we're only going to put this much in for
the meantime and
i 100 agree with
councillor stewart's comments that will
then
lead the community itself to decide what
do we want to do then and can we get
other money from other sources so this
is intended i suppose to to limit your
exposure if if you agree to this while
this consultation will still occur
and there will be expectations out there
is that that are already in place
because of our other work in terms of
strategy this report won't escalate that
it'll
it'll do the opposite i'm hoping
um
yeah
it's sort of chicken and egg of it isn't
it if we go back to the community boys
whether we're talking new stuff or
upgrading
is there not a strong inference there
that that whatever they decide where
we're going to allow the budget which is
a for
at a council level which is actually a
separate issue to whatever they decide
to do is that you're okay with that
i 100 agree and we did think about
whether this was indeed the right thing
to be doing we are sending a signal to
your community out there that
this is the importance if that's the
right word this is the the importance
you put on this particular issue
we i think we ended up concluding that
was a good message to send them even
though it's a little bit of a hard
message this early in the process
because vanessa in particular was
indicating quite a strong risk that we
could well be spending the next five or
six months consulting with people and
the next you see is some very fine plans
that are all being drawn up and they
look lovely
and everybody has an expectation and the
next you say is sorry we're not going to
fund that for the next three or four
years and everybody ends up disappointed
with the outcome this is hoping to
match that expectation right from the
start
you know don's explained a fair bit of
that i think but
i mean the basic question i've got are
we going to eat up this 50 000 for the
next three years just in their own
bureaucracy of getting to the end of the
story because it costs an awful lot to
actually get the plans up there and find
out what it is that people want
so i'm wondering if the 50 000 is
actually going to get us to the plan per
year
or
and then we're going to do the funding
of the
quantum gates for whatever you want to
call them
you know we are we really managing any
expectation
it is a very good comment and that
vanessa has pointed out she's
effectively working for free on this
particular project and that she has many
projects which don't get funded
specifically against the accounts she's
working on
and and simon in particular was quite
keen to see if you could hand this off
to another staff member
who could build time against a specific
project we internally have not yet had
that conversation about where internal
costs will lie
if it does
turn into something that internal costs
were needing to be shed at home you've
got a very fair point about this this
money
won't all be for them physical works
because some of it will have been used
up elsewhere
casa mailings
with regard to the
the urban entrances you know that that
makes sense to me because those are more
clearly delineated but what strategy
have you got to delineate the
settlements i see that that's your stage
too but but just from my own experience
with the hookah residents association
um we
as an association
um
designed and and and worked with council
to um implement the installation of
those settlement signs but you wouldn't
believe the debate of where the entrance
to ohoka was and where where it began
where it ended where i mean we actually
even lost the secretary because she was
deemed not to live in a hoka she was
upset
so um and and i see that you've got us
down um
that that you've got us down there as
population 3195 in the ahoka mandeville
area i dare say that you would be very
hard-pressed to find somebody that would
be happy with
um
and a hoca sign up in mandeville and
vice versa they're they're
it in and then you you find a difficulty
in in delineating what's where because
in the rural areas it's not so clear and
and where one one settlement bleeds into
the next so have you got a
i did ask you before so have you got a
way to get around that otherwise i think
that could be a too hard basket
we feel we haven't actually looked that
far into it yet
um i i guess it'll be just looking at
where a congregation of houses are on
the map i don't know it's something um
yeah we'll have to explore and come back
to you on that one i think but thanks
for raising it it's a good point
you're absolutely right councillor and
we know
over time that this is an absolute
challenge
to put it politely to actually get a
result in the space and i suppose what
this report's trying to signal is um we
actually don't think you should invest
too much effort in that unless you're
prepared to invest some serious money in
is this really the priority for our
community at this time and i think
the answer we're trying to i think if
adopting these recommendations today the
answer clearly to our community is uh
for some time we're not really going to
be investing in this with a great deal
of effort and energy and if
um
if
they and then you want something
different to that in the quantums that
we would have to spend in this space
substantial
and
fraught
with challenge trying to get a once
you've agreed where the sign should go
then what the sign should be
is equally a challenge and it's um
[Music]
uh something we think we've got better
energy to invest in
and my last point was i think the staff
will bring this strategy to you on
settlements in a couple of months and i
think that would be the ideal
opportunity for you to
the staff have a rationale for why
they've chosen the nine settlements
if you believe it should be a different
mix
that should come through as a
recommendation from you at the time you
see that strategy in front of you
it's been good questions council brian's
indicated wants to move seconded
is it council records you indicate
second
council brian
thank you mister
um
all this is doing is putting some money
into the draft ltp
that return
will
get feedback
not only from the community boards but
also the general public as to whether 50
000 in the budget is money well spent in
the current environment and moving this
today is not any indication that i will
vote in favor of it next year
it just gets into the big picture uh
which is where it needs to be quite
frankly
okay i agree with council blind rather
interesting i just uh councillor and
brian and i indicated to each other
after mr christensen's report that uh
sort of 160 million dollars went through
the flick of a hat but we can't decide
what we should do at town entrances so
uh it's rather relevant really but uh i
agree that it's going to the right place
at the present time we'll
thrash our way through it there
put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carry
thanks vanessa and don thank you
okay
actually well we will move along to the
next report which is 8.10
a contribution to local rsa clubs this
is a report in
my name this follows
a discussion that we had on
proposed this on a one of our zoom calls
so it's just seeking a contribution to
our like three local rsa uh welfare
funds and know of the anzac contribution
the council would normally make to the
community by way of health and safety um
work plus also the wreaths that we
produce and all the support that we give
to the local area says in the production
of it
i had a conversation with bj clark who's
the president of
new zealand rsa
they are not planning to do a poppy day
this year
um
and
also just to make sure that there was no
you know where where the strategy might
be at a national level
um and i've talked to our local rsas
with the exception of cust um and
ranging
in the recommendation it's got a
thousand for each of rengara and kaipo
and the reason for that is that they do
support more than one service
cast
is recommending 500 which uh because
they they just do customer stations so
it was just a contribution
uh there seemed to be general agreement
when we talked about it on the zoom
course that's why i bought it forward as
a report
i'm happy to answer any questions
questions
some are prepared to move moved by
oh sorry question first
council williams
i'm not quite familiar with the um
uh shift and we go up there for an rsa
service and um and all those other
places oxford as well not mentioned here
um
i don't know the situation there can you
give me a bit of background on him
bengurus supports both sefton and oxford
um
that's the way it is uh cust actually
there they um
relationships with christchurch rsa kaya
poi supports sort of uh
kaipui and
ahoka is supported alternately by um
both rengara and kyboy are say to ahui's
kapoy
wood end is now kai poi
so those that we were never going to be
able to find a perfect solution but by
making a contribution to those rsas
it was picking up the bulk uh and it's
just a contribution it's never going to
be there's never going to be all the
amount that we set aside which is
normally in the order of near 20 000 so
this was just a small contribution to
those rsas and
the welfare support that they they won't
have now at the same revenue because
they haven't had the poppy day this year
so
yeah okay so
someone prepared to move council blacky
seconded by councillor atkinson council
blacky
council reckinson
just echo what you said you made a very
fine debate you missed me
uh council duty did you wish to say
the speakers
so i'll put that
put that all those in favor aye
contrary declare that carried thank you
um men's has referred for
from committees and community boards i
have none health sorry hold on
sorry jim there wasn't
i'm in the right space so that's good um
health and safety 10.1 german pages
three three three three two three four
six
take the report has read happy to answer
any questions thank you mr mayor
questions
sorry just one question mr palmer just
wondering how you're monitoring the
health uh the
sort of mental well-being of our staff
during these tricky times if you could
just give us a bit more information on
that
yep so we have
a
we've had a um
a survey of staff
that
allows people to volunteer or
voluntarily update at any time and a
part of that question is you know are
you okay and do you need any help
the first time we put that out we had i
think
mid 40s number of staff responded and
one or two signaled that they weren't
coping so well so we
supported them to the best of our
ability we've got our
both our
human resources health and safety staff
and eap services there to support
anybody who's
needing that support
we are undertaking a survey
at
at the moment just started it to staff
to say what did they find
worked well what didn't
how are they have they coped
so to get a little bit of
some metrics back around that um
other than that it's anecdotal anecdotal
support and contact which
is intended to happen regularly between
supervisors and staff
bearing in mind the
high consequences of of that
would that be included in the next
health and safety report
i think we're happy to give you any
generalized feedback that we can provide
in that space yes
the questions some are prepared to move
your question
because of duty
how does that affect the counsellors are
they included in on this or is it a
separate thing altogether or are we
exempt from it
so i think that same survey was uh
distributed to councillors and the
opportunity to participate i don't know
how many took up
the answers don't come back to me so i'm
not sure how many actually took up that
opportunity to comment
um
i can answer that question anecdotally i
haven't talked to sarah in detail about
it but it did there were
quite a large number of you actually did
respond in from boards as well there
were
no major issues expressed through
through that that we should be concerned
about but it was an opportunity and
people can submit on that as often as
they or
take part in it as often as they like so
but i thought it was a very good
exercise and a really good initiative
that came through from liz and the hr
team
just to connect with people to see how
everyone was doing so
um that's that's all there is to update
on that at this point
council duty is prepared to move
seconded by council the bar that council
of duty
oh that's fine thank you
refer the speakers i'll put that all
those in favor aye contrary to clear
that carriage
there's no committee minutes for
information
community boards for information that
it's mentioned there due to covert 19
there hasn't well there's been zoom
calls but not formal meetings
reports there's no reports for
information we come to item 14 which is
my damier's diary
item 4.1
it's you know i'm happy to answer any
questions
someone prepared to move
moved by council atkinson second by
council award any
any discussion
i'll put that all those in favor please
say i
contrary to clear that caring so we come
to council portfolio updates i'm just
appreciative in the interest of time
members could keep these just brief
please
so eerie relationships just briefly um
we've got the mahitahi um coming up a
meeting coming up shortly
because well i hope there is um i think
we're still establishing the settling
the date but that um i've seen a date
being circulated
um and both the chief executive and i
have um kept in touch by zoom with
tomorrow
um through this exercise so that's all i
have to update is there any questions of
me
can it be water uh management strategy
counselor stuart
thank you mr mayor the major as you be
aware is um
the announcement of the pending
mps freshwater that was um
last week with um
implementation uh in july
so i understand um it has major
implications for us
and i think there will be an update to
the water zone committee on
monday
at their meeting
i think it's in the agenda we're just
getting it now
[Music]
so i think
we should schedule if we haven't already
got a planned a an update to this
council
um about um uh how how it affects us and
our waterways
the other thing
is that if it in fact goes
and is
adopted
as is indicated by the government it
will certainly need to be given effect
to and in fact i think we've just got a
note come through this afternoon
that in fact that is the case it will
need to be given effect to in the pc7
hearings which haven't actually been
scheduled at this point
um so it um
it does up the ante considerably for um
what is required under pc7 uh
particularly some things like um having
having
water quality improved within a
generation
and nitrate levels
tailored to that whereas they were going
out 60 to
30 90 years
as far as i can see while the government
has is reviewing in a year the um
dissolved an organic nitrate the
nitrogen level that was one milligram it
does say in the cabinet papers
2.4 milligrams is where it's heading and
that's a major for our
rivers kaiapoi and silver stream which
are
well over um at the bottom line at the
moment
um so there's that to
deal with and we'll learn more about it
in the next
few weeks i suspect and i'm having a
meeting on friday with ecan's new river
engineer and fred brooks who's who's
taken over from retired brian neck and
joe
those of you who go past along
the river will see the the ivy getting
away up the trees that you can take care
of on the parkway river
and brock's um acknowledges that that is
not a
level of service that is acceptable in
an urban area
so i'm meeting with him and chris brown
and a few um
perhaps grant mccabe coming along in the
talk so i can report back on where we
get to where i'd like to get to is that
fred will come along and talk about
getting rid of the ivy they're going to
poison it um and then a planting program
for the whole length of
the urban area of the kaiapoi riverbanks
questions of council stuart
thank you council stuart international
relationship stephanie mia atkinson
anything to any questions of counsel
atkinson
thank you um
regeneration counselor becky
thank you mr mayor um bridging has fired
up again um we had divers down in the
river over the weekend um amongst other
amongst other things the good news they
found was that since the bridging was
done last
year the river there is no there is no
additional salt which means the salt
silt sell dry silk which means the river
isn't silting up which was always a
worry after our dredging how fast it
would um regress and we'd have to do it
again so that's so that's fairly good
news
we had a meeting uh regen had a meeting
on thursday to discuss the more swing
moorings versus pile moorings and the
ownership and the transfer of boats etc
etc and um councillor atkinson very
kindly stood in for me because i'd run
away to the sounds so that's that is an
ongoing dialogue
karaki
carpark is progressing well that heap of
rubbish vessel from the wharf has gone
tim smith has taken it away and we're
hallelujah
and roading's proceeding well
duncan and his team have taken on board
the fact that some of that roading may
if well happened to happen
some of that roading is
where they don't want a road so they're
within the within the parameters of the
contract they're they're doing minimal
things this is the road to ash keaton to
the launching ramp so they're doing
their best to keep it it was always a
minimal level of service anyway that
road and they're trying to
keep it down to as little spend as
little money as possible on it the
irrigation of the playing fields is
finished just has to be commissioned
tiger turf is working starting any day
now with the permitting on the
diamonds and um watson hughes uh kicking
off on the um changing rooms at the um
at the playing fields
thank you
thanks counselor black any questions
thank you councillor mainly sorry was it
a question counselor
very busy
thank you uh councillor mailings
thank you
um yes so from the sustainability and
climate change point of view you've all
just heard mike o'connell's lovely
report and all of the details are in
there for you to read
he is as he said working on stage two of
the sustainability
strategy and with regard to climate
change there is a an
in progress as yet uncompleted inventory
on things that we are doing to address
climate change um and veronica spittle
is working on drafting up climate change
policy for council as we speak
and um
i i would just like to just iterate
that
coven 19 has shown us
that the changes that we thought were in
the too hard basket and that that
couldn't happen and wouldn't be able to
happen quickly we've done all those
things we've we've shown the leadership
that we needed we have made the changes
that we needed for covet 19 those are
very very similar to what we need to
address climate change and
sustainability issues let's not learn
let's not lose that lesson
that's it from me thanks guys
thanks thanks nicki any questions
thank you
so i have no questions no urgent general
business
uh so that we now come to matches to be
considered by the public excluded
there's a recommendation that someone
prefer to move
you